on est parti ça a dû fonctionner
on va envoyer le raid
ça devrait jouer
y'a pas de masque williams à ce qu'il
y'a pas masquer d'ailleurs
ça va être intéressant de voir sur les
cannes du coup masque ou pas masquer la
gelac amanti
les calmes qui marchent pas
à masquer non mais enfin j'ai quasiment
vide rage quit le
la retransmission je trouve ça
ouais je trouve ça vraiment répartis
très particulier honnêtement
honnêtement
sa cascade l'ambiance 1
même un petit peu l'ambiance je connais
mon maxime il va être en masques et tout
s'est tellement respectueux
type se mouche dans les mains il serre
la main on en a mais bon c
c'est vrai nom c'est très très partie
honnêtement c'est très particulière
c'est très très particulier
c'est ouais c'est franchement c'est bon
j'ai pas j'ai pas trop les mots après
chacun chacun sa sensibilité aussi mais
moi je suis un peu
j'ai pas envie de dire choquée parce que
c'est pas le mot mais
dérange et on va dire ça comme ça
c'est jusque voir ils peuvent être
négatif ou quoi on s'est pas tu peux tu
peux avoir prendre des mesures de
précaution
sas a tué personne à me mettre un masque
et de pas serrer la main j'appelle
jamais personne qui en est mort 1
ça me paraît quand même être des mesures
de bon sens
quand on ne sait pas ce genre de mesure
de précaution on sait pas
et pour éviter un
alors attends devrait mettre dans le bon
sens c'est maxime qui a les noirs
et pour éviter les problèmes
que ça fait de mal à personne
ça peut pas faire de mal en tout cas
mettre un masque et pas serré la main ne
peut pas empirer la situation donc vu
que ça coûte rien autant le faire hein
bon on espère que maxime va gagner je
peux vous assurer à mon avis je suis sûr
à 95 % que maxime lui fait bien
attention et donc il va se pénaliser
c'est juste un presse-purée cautionner
sa garantie réelle c'est exactement ça
martine x10 je sais pas c'est un
principe l'option je suis pas médecin
super pino mollo épidémiologistes je
sais pas exactement mais au pire ça sert
à rien au mieux ça aide au pire ça sert
à rien
ça me paraît quand même spécial non peu
importe
faux a3c prend des cats et prend des
quatre dames c'est cette peut-être
un pascalien un pari pascalien bien vu
jeanny pg c'était la réf en plus c'était
vraiment la réf le pari de pascal
désolé du coup ça m'a un peu ça va un
peu déstabilisé ça va un petit peu
déstabilisés
surtout bon sens donne quand même un
petit peu l'exemple quand on est sportif
de haut niveau aussi coiffe un bon peu
importe elle va plus parler de ça sinon
ça va m'énerver
donc on va essayer de se lancer dans la
partie on sera on sera bien de
commentaires dès la deuxième et il faut
surtout que maxime gagne
un cas
cinq états damas cinq qui va partir
on n'a pas la cam sur maximin donc on va
voir si maxime s'en sort il va faire fou
au 6e tour des 5
mais je comprends pas pourquoi
pourquoi du bafa gagné par forfait
puisque normalement quand tu prends un
bail enfin quand tu te retires d'un
tournoi s'était retiré du tournoi était
plus à parier donc j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi double of gagne par
forfait contre contre naka je pense que
ça à l'encontre de la règle mais je suis
pas sûr s'il ya un ca des arbitres dans
le tchat
sortie
et du coup quand les appariements sont
sortis la veille tu peux pas tu peux pas
prendre un bail après on t'a 13 gars qui
gagnent par forfait
c'est incroyable ça aussi
on va voir si maxime fait quelque chose
c'est quand même
et quand même un cas très particulier là
il est il est forfait j'ai envie j'ai
envie de dire c'est quasiment un cas de
force majeure en réalité le forfait de
de naka
je pensais qu'en dans ce genre de cas de
figure il était prévu que le que les
appariements soir fait
j'aurais imaginé mais après par
apparemment c'est pas la règle mais
c'est je suis assez étonné de cette
règle a aussi
fait publier en fait il n'y a pas de cas
de force majeure ou quoi joue pas au
hockey
bon maxime là qui est pas
pas vraiment le dessus j'espère qu'il va
réussir à bien bien se concentrer parce
que connaissant maxime qui a quand même
petite tendance à un petit
il peut
s'appuyer fortement l'énervé il faut
vraiment qu'ils rentrent bien la
première partie est vraiment décisive là
pour le joueur français
m
il va ya bref quattro
et appsync cours et maxime maxime qui en
turbo troll malheureusement on suivra
ali reza la prochaine ainsi sa paire
côté maxime
alors pour les pendules faut regarder
celles qui sont au dessus ça le sel de
gauche
sont généralement un peu buggé
maximale qui peut peut-être bouffer à 2
marrant ça qu'ils aient pas pris le pion
généralement quand il peut manger un
pion maxime ils le mangent
mais il veut faire [ __ ] en c5 vous
prend à deux et jouer un peu sur ce clou
âge
ça lui évitera de se prendre un aussi
ces chèques pénible et c'est pour ça
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait c'est 5 d'abord
nancy s'il a vu le pion à 2 mai mais
aussi se faisait peur
bon alors position allait nulle après ça
dépend si galles font de vous le gard ou
pas
bref si tu vas peut-être faire faut
prendre cette d'impro cette dame prend à
deux
et jouer la finale mais généralement sur
ces finales de dames ça ne peut que
faire annuler d'heure c'est plus à
maxime de chercher la drau
maxime qui va pas s'imposer avec les
noirs alors ça aurait été très embêtant
si avait pas eu autant de forfaits on va
voir ce serait bien de jouer n'a qu'à la
prochaine marie va être sorti du tournoi
malheureusement
on verra combien nakashi de ce
championnat du monde de blitz à mon avis
va pas il va pas être très bien classés
d'un bep ci semble pas aller parce que
le roi va être dans le carré
d'un
trt 6 d'un point 4 et ce qui va tenter
samira dam des six échecs
il fait dams et 6 maxime qui a peut-être
cacher le roi maintenant
et je pense que karlsson a gagné 1 ça se
voit de façon maclou c'est un peu le
client
pas ma vie 3g cette ouais c'est ça va
bouffer en a 5 et bouffer e4
des 2 h 5 pions plus pour boris golf
hand mais la finale doit être nul 1 il
ya trop de perpète mais s'il ya
quelqu'un qui gagne c'est bien
évidemment boris 1
à gaza fait n'importe quoi
aïe aïe aïe les deux français qui
pourrait être sorti du tournoi
à
iai dialogue quel mauvais début de
journée
ali haddad fait signer alireza c'est
terminé alireza ne fait pas un grand
tournoi il a eu un gros rush mais le
rush est terminée et maxime qui a gagné
c'est gagné pour maxime alors je sais
pas comment mais il est annoncé à 0,1
alors il ya peut-être eu nul hein y'a
peut-être c'est peut-être tomber côté
boris et oui et oui le retour à l'ehpad
procès gagné ça a l'air je suis pas sûr
parce qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas de
contact visuel mais ça semblerait avoir
gagné côté e côté ministre et ça ça ça
serait la très belle nouvelle à victoire
ici mais très bien parce que ça te
psychologiquement ça fait du bien
ça fait du bien de gagner cette partie
avec avec un pion de man en finale de
dame mais boris a dû tomber j'imagine un
j'imagine tombe aide victoire méritée de
maxime allais ça remonte
par il se remet bien la maxime encore
une victoire 2 à la prochaine et on est
dedans
alors que malheureusement macho de
l'homme aclu a perdu
macho de loup a perdu
terrible
à rien ce qu'il a fait rien paris non
c'est pilote qui a battu nguyen et ce
qui n'a pas dû ariane tahri dont je ne
crois pas les bons qui a gagné il a
battu amine ben hassen et c'était sur un
bassem c'était le péno
terrible
du boeuf camurat nakamura qui a perdu 1
défaite di caro contre dan îles du golfe
le joueur américain qui s'incline il n'a
pas réussi à répondre aux coups eux
quatre
c'est une lourde défaite pour le joueur
américain
qui va avoir du mal en ce tournant à
remonter maintenant il est bloqué à 8
points et demi sur 13 et on va voir
ainsi réussi à faire un meilleur score
ouais c'est c'est difficile cette
deuxième journée il a il en a peut-être
pas assez dans le coffre hikaru on va
voir si réussi à faire plus de la
moyenne dans ce tournoi et qui réussit à
dépasser les 10 points et demi mais il
devrait avoir du mal dans ce championnat
du monde il risque iris de finir au delà
de la 100e place hikaru
excellent blitzer sur le net mais
beaucoup plus de mal
mais mentalement il est il est dans le
dur il est dans le dur mentalement le
joueur américain
peut-être une désillusion 1
c'est une
fusion
c'est terrible
il va falloir être fort dans la tête
pour icare où
il va falloir être très fort dans la
tête
simon garayev qui a gagné contre qui
murale simon connaît pas
gmac en fait s'appelle simon mais il a
racheté un z dans son prénom gimont
magnifique
c'est beaucoup mieux simon que simon 1
c'est magnifique simon avec un s z y
passait très mal
orthographié magnifique
seul coup d'après la pièce perdue à la
pendule ouais je crois qu'il a pas
réussi à réagir à eux quatre
jeux convaincue elle gagne le renomme
plus sain pour les blancs et difficile
semble pas cette flaque bas je pense
qu'il a gagné il a fait tomber 1 il n'a
pas pu abandonner et ils ont pas fait
nul
si on vous déjà éliminé un maxima gagner
un
magnifique cette victoire
il faut poser laisse ouvertes sur mon
petit naka terrible
c'est magnifique 1 au crac offs a perdu
contre et gorze
un mine basse amine ben hassen mais
c'est tellement dommage tellement de
beaux lui contre maxime va
ste bol qu'il a eu c'est pas possible il
ya encore un réel tahri qui joue le plot
le plot banc contre adam kosa qu
aller le plot elle plots
le plot qui est pas mal le plot blanc
entre kozak
il va falloir la gagner celle-là
moi je regarde taille basse et
ça nos joueurs préférés 1
c'est quand même le plot le plus fort
plus haut du monde très dangereux
il va réussir à faire là nul bien jouer
ariane qui tire une nulle contre 1 25 26
magnifique résultat d'ailleurs c'est une
vitrine comme je l'inviterai ariane
paris hausse et obliger
absolument obligatoire prochaine big
three cups ariane paris sera invité au
boys au bon on veut le voir contre le
prez ça va être magnifique bakhit a ri
quoi ça peut être un match ça peut ça
peut partir
ça peut être magnifique
petit point classement alors petit point
classement à voir que j'aille le voir -
le classement
alors le point classement qui va partir
le point classement qui va partir
je vais vous dire je vais vous faire un
classement
instantanément
le classement n'est pas encore sorti
mais dès qu'il ya un classement je vous
le donne
feront les infos sur tu as raison
c'est le meilleur site pour les
classements mais en gros maxime va être
pas mal hein
maxime va bien remonté il va être à 9
points il dépasse naka je pense que
maxime finira devant hikaru nakamura
dans ce tournoi
probable
pas de classement mais oui va il va il
va être bien maxime problème c'est que
les vont un peu d'avancé mais
en fait maxime il est dans le bon groupe
là
il gagne la prochaine il est vraiment
dans
les bons on
c'est que les bons il va encore jouer
magnus et il va encore jouer et maxime
qui peut l'arrêter peut-être la 5g mai
mais peut-être m vélo 6 1
c'est carsen
votre battu car ça ne va battre les bons
façon les bons il va pas faire neuf sur
ma faim ça va commencer à craquer là il
a joué le dernier plus haut possible
ça va arrêter les plots un côté les bons
in his way je pense que ça peut il peut
se faire magnus aide
maxime il peut jouer beaucoup de monde
j'espère qu'il va pas jouer cardiaque
cardiac peut être chiant
ah
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait duda
une vraie question sein d'air c'est une
question importante
kirill pour les bonnes il arrive à
enchaîner les plots quoi est ce possible
va jouer magnus à
va a perdu très bonne nouvelle
ok j'ai les classements
il ya un un ennemi d'avant match
maxime est dans un groupe avec que des
rousses coffre qu'elle est dans le
groupe avec nemo artemiev sahara n'a
cardiaque grischa forêt qui joue grisha
maxime faut que maxime joue grisha au
blanc
après un groupe à neuf et demi dans mais
maxime en fait il est complètement
dedans il est complètement dedans de
français
lvl guéri et merde il au noir chier
d'être noir contre guiry
flûte
à il est au noir contre guy quelle
malchance
il fait flotteurs montant au noir flûte
martirossian karl scène à renier ni riga
ici valérie ya ici un le prince du gange
ouais en fait la foudre au là faut pas
forcer faux draw et aller gagner au
blanc à la prochaine
allez l importance et la contre le
gastronome en culottes courtes aux
îliens jolie fille rousse gens contre
luca moroni le joueur italien streamer
alors que dans le groupe des lâchers à
huit et demi il ya aussi hikaru nakamura
engluée dans ce groupe à huit et demi
voyez pas bien à cas
il est pas bien au lion carrément
disqualifié il est déclassé il ne sera
pas classé dans ce championnat il est
classé
naka qui pour le moment est 20e
na carré 20e on verra où il finit ce
championnat du monde de blitz
pour le moment 20e on verra à quel et
quelle est sa place
c'est terrible c'est terrible illégalité
avec moroni
22e
c'est terrible
fuir ou une fille rhoufir où il est loin
et 33e c'est mort
cheyrou c'est vraiment marrant il fait
pas un bon tournoi balle et maxime
compte guéri faut faire le plus tôt à
maigrir il a neuf et demi
si maxime gagne il revient dans le top
10 1
métier comment
un cas au bar où il joue pas mal hein
donc
15 heures
1 lacam wendel en fin de journée
possible
lundi soir les frictions avec les noirs
même si t'es pas 100% clip c'était une
grosse partie de merde en fait
il a même pas vraiment attaquer et c'est
l'autre qui est tombé tout seul mais
c'est pas grave
prendre les cadeaux qu'on te fais un
griot blanc c'est cool gear noir c'est
chaud
voir
comment ça va se
passer il ya sarah martin f
ben ouais
guéri c'est être le pire appariement
possible
chance quand même d'être quand même
appareillés contre makassed incroyable
ça
incroyable simple
raté son freinage ça et qui sait rien du
tout tu auras ton premier match s'est
enfin
fait un genre de sous marins mais gagné
par forfait un moment comme ça du
tournoi c'est une chance incroyable
kft maxime
vaut mieux pas perdre
cette future oif
on n'a qu'à maintenant il sera plus à
parier
ya que du boeuf qui profitera de
cet avantage
non il va être il va être sorti du
tournoi là
là il va être sorti du tournoi il sera
plus jamais à pareille
malheureusement
martirossian c'est un score 1
allez faut aller chercher celle là elle
est ultra importante
salat remettre maxime dans le tournoi
sim si les tables 3 je peux avoir une
cam
l étable quatre
tables 4 sa patte padam padam
bas de gamme
ims a bientôt commencer absolument
gagner
nul est passable gagnait te remet dans
la course quoi pour pour la première
place
nitorem est vraiment heureux mais
vraiment dedans quoi
ce qu'on croit tacklé vonn qui est
vraiment loin devant mais il peut
complètement s'écrouler à tout moment
déjà la guérilla ici lui prend fin ce tu
gagnes en fait à dix points erika ici
lui prend un demi point et refait nul
contre carl scène tu deviens pointe à
portée de fusil tu es là en fait
c'est les coûts de maxime plus qu'autre
chose mais à
c'est les cookies main qui m'inquiète
je trouve pas exceptionnel pour le
moment mais ça peut venir
ça va sûrement partir
bon mais la première game peut mettre en
confiance je gagne la contre-guérilla
prêtait très confiant
amine est dommage oui elle mais le met
un peu de temps après
allez ça parle cavalière froide anish
giri ce que maxime va jouer des cinq
comme toujours dans ce tournant il fait
ses 5 maxime qui ressort de ces armes
principales contrat nigeria niche qui
veut jouer 3 pour jouer des cadres dans
cette anglaise maxime va peut-être
envoyer un pion en dessine qu'aux non il
fait au sein qui joue à une structure
bobigny qui est maintenant des 5 maxime
qui va jouer les taux de marc auxi et
non puisqu'il n'ya pas des taux il ya eu
des katja d échange massif cette
position-là déjà vu sur la chaîne c'est
un petit avantage blanc dans la finale
que guillery va obtenir on l'avait vu
dans aux grands suisses cette position
je pense ronde 1
contre anthony mann je crois qu'on avait
vu ça c'est une position assez égal
maxime ici il doit jouer tranquille doit
pas prendre de risques inconsidérés à
aller chercher un demi point si si le
peut c'est pas forcément très agréable à
jouer puisque avec les dents on a ce
pion c6 qui est potentiellement faible
maxime qui envoie le cavalier en d5 sur
qui a valu aux trois il veut couper
quatre échecs j'imagine fou d2 et il
aura peut-être du cavalier 3 c'est pour
ça qui l'a commencée avec petit rock
avec les blancs fou hausse est
maintenant il va jouer tout revient
peut-être avec l'idée sur roc d'avoir
fou prend des 5 et gagner le le fou le
fou au 7 mai sur tours 1 maxime va jouer
fou aux six et il va couvrir la colonne
c'est pas quelque chose de très
ambitieux qui est joué ici par anish
giri qui est peut-être désintéressé un
de la victoire du tournoi ils préfèrent
peut-être faire des petites nul pleutre
pour être bien sûr de prendre des 2000
points mais côté français c'est le titre
de champion du monde qui nous intéresse
donc il va falloir accepter l'attitude
de l'adversaire laisser prendre là nul
au cas où et revenir plus fort dans la
prochaine partie avec les blancs
cependant si maxime peut avoir une
occasion de planter une combinaison
tactique il ne s'en privera pas anish
giri qui développe son cavalier ans et
trois fois aux 6 maxime qui doit
vraiment jouer ici tranquille mais
peut-être le fou en existe au prochain
coup ramener les tours au centre
et la tenir comme je vous disais à long
terme il peut y avoir des petits soucis
liés aux aura la structure de piola il
faut quand même calculé qui est france
et trois sur vous pour une scission
n'aura cavalier e 2 non car il prend ses
trois tours prend ces trois ans devrait
peut-être un fou b4 pour échanger
massivement les pièces est allé faire la
petite nul tant espéré par anish ça peut
être une option tout rêve des huit peut
en être une autre on va voir ce que ce
que maxime décide de faire et ses trois
tours ces trois fous b4 il doit regarder
un tour ces deux il doit espérer avoir
une barre loterie fou prend ses quatre
fous prend des quatre fous prend en f1
ça a l'air de passer de justesse il a du
beau lui à nice guy ici il a le beau lui
parce que ça c'est genre de choses qui
peuvent ne pas passer du tout pensé
quatre points f1 vous prend au profit de
fou détroit quel beau lui au profit de
fous des trois tours ces trois tours eu
huit ans il est il est vraiment à deux
doigts de la perdre guéri terrible
terrible faute rangée de est une autre
option fou pranger sept fous des
5es suroît projet d'europe profite
s'arrête un stand drouot à l était pas
loin maxime
à il était pas long d'avoir le beau lui
il a été il n'est pas passé loin aniche
qui à la petite réussite qui met bien
pour faire la drau
maxime pouvait rien faire d'autre 1 là
contre les blancs contre un joueur qu'il
veut faire nul un joueur qui ne souhaite
pas devenir champion du monde c'est
difficile à tous qu'il espère c'est de
bloquer ses adversaires
mais une nulle rapide n'est pas un
mauvais résultat ici un ce a permis de
récupérer maximale et noir il joue un
adversaire direct quand même qui en
embêtera plus d'un
et l'annuler prise c'est pas c'est pas
un mauvais résultat ici comme je vous le
disais normalement on voulait commencer
par deux sur deux mais au vu des
appariements au vue du doublement des
des pièces noires c'est pas si mauvais
après il faut pas que les jeunes
prennent complètement le large on va
voir ce que fait ait martirossian contre
magnus carlsen le joueur arménien très
dangereux
peuvent se balader doit encore gagner je
sais pas je n'ai pas pas spécialement
d'autres résultats on peut jeter aussi
un oeil par curiosité à la partie 2 les
bonnes
les bonnes qui gère 1 qui gère bien son
tournoi
il est bien dans son tournoi le joueur
américain
et ait martirossian attention il va pas
falloir donner trop de cases à magnus h5
qui va peut-être partir
terry
pour il protège le plus ardu âge sinko
on va voir
ce que ça je vous côté à côté magnus ici
peut-être h 5 1 pour se gagner les cases
va peut-être prendre
et détroit il va se replacer on va voir
un martirossian dangereux
mais une basse est en perdition c'est
pas étonnant à mine basse m
il était très au classement un mieux que
ce qui peut faire entre guillemets
taussat h5
c'est pas sûr que magnus réussissent à
la gagner un celle-là
martirossian et
si malins
qui est pas si mal on va voir
six cavaliers
t3f 6 cavaliers h4 ses parts à jouer ça
de la part
d' high qui va peut-être fait le pion h5
les anges et si ça il y aura f5 après
tour c'est un roi 17 ça fait pas grand
chose ce coup c'est un petit peu un coup
d'épée dans l'eau
h5 g5 un g6 f5
ces trois
oppositions on la sent bien pour carlson
sais pas ce que c'est car scène qui au
noir un
laïc qui veut remettre leur en f2
pris ce prix ce qui a valu au cices f5
et c5 bouffe bouffe
pas mettre le carillon des 3 plus tôt
pour aller vers eux cinq
courses et c'est un pur pour colmater
f5 qui a valu aux cinq attention magnus
quand même il ya du cac et 17 qui traîne
maintenant
qui peut être dangereux
qui est tour g8 qui était 7,3 ses sept
cavaliers affichent 6 attention il peut
y avoir des petites magouilles qui tape
étape
ça a été joué différemment ça a pris on
sait pas trop ce qui se passe sur leurs
cavaliers apprécient c'est peut-être
maintenant
tour qui va venir en des huit pour
bloquer les chèques
cet ours et gien à présent qui a validé
cette quand même à wittes on prend 17
ans prend à schwyz
c'est malin
il revient aux cinq sémalens que
féérique
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt les
blancs qui presse ici à tous peut
réellement arrivé dans cette dans cette
partie
là la grande cas maintenant
ça échange s'est pas dit que magnus la
gagne celle là
la tour qui revient en g8 qui tape le
cheval
y avoir quoi tour h7
il fait qui a valu aux cinq tours j'ai
cette attention
il va peut-être mettre la tour en
achètent faut qu'ils essayent de rentrer
elle est partie avec tours h5 ouais
c'est s'étend du 1 comme game
et des six sur roy g3 il veut revenir en
rêve 5
il le joue quand même
il doit revenir en f2 qui a aidé 6
magnus qui veulent annuler
à iquique mieux autant
il remet la tour ainsi s'il veut chasser
le cheval en tout cas lui mettre un coup
de pression
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué mais je n'ai pas
pu voir le coup j'ai un fonds qui va
jouer un b 6 ou un b 5
il va mettre la torah f6 j'imagine
ouais on est à deux doigts de gagner la
côte à
côte et blanc
magnus dans le dur hein elle peut coûter
très cher ça la magnus il perd ce qu'il
a perdu du matos ou pas il la tient pour
le moment le champion du monde peut-être
pour plus si longtemps ils proposent les
changes détour c'est bien joué ça
échange f4 qui ont passé de chaque côté
la position qui doit logiquement être
drôle
qui avec 4 way et ça fait nul à et qui a
pas réussi à la gagner je vois que
s'échangent quelques sourires
ouais c'était pas loin c'était pas loin
du dac
va être dur à bali firoud qui a réussi à
battre luca moroni qui remonte un petit
peu
qu'est-ce qu'on a eu d'autres les vents
et vont ça a fait nul
à levon qui a tout donné
ils étaient pas -
n'était pas la gagner double off et de
beau jeu les pales à la partie
avec thank you qui va battre annales il
a raté le gard les bons c'est une bonne
nouvelle quand même c'est quand même
plutôt une bonne nouvelle il faut pas
qu'ils prennent trop large faut pas
avoir plus de deux points de retard la
maxime est un peu derrière mais dès
qu'ils gagnent de game en fait il se
remet complètement
est ce qu'on a martirosyan danané pour
dubaï d'où peuvent qu il va être chaud
et minerais
parce que vas-tu famine
un minerai
dubois flat qui se remet vraiment bien
classement ça va donner un truc way qui
restent derrière quand même il falloir
gagner une ou deux parties d'affilée 1
en fait rue noël
avec 5 go qui gagne un corps il était à
8 et nirvana fait demi
magnus peu flotteurs descendants n'ont
pas flotter descendants magnus
il faut qu'ils fassent pour gagner mais
faut qu'il enchaîne les victoires
si vous aviez roues il faut que tu
fasses 7 sur 7 maxime si ça passe
peut-être
j'ai oublié
maxime ça lui a quand même coûté
relativement cher 1 sont
sont ils tenteront guillemer la défaite
contre amine
couple est derrière à la défaite
contre toulouse c'est ça qui le met dans
le malin il aurait un point de plus
disons il serait dans le bon groupe 1
il paye ce point quoi
après
kong alphand là
ça compense un peu
j'ai pas content qui va jouer à la
prochaine
aucune idée de qui va jouer la prochaine
à bien un petit alexis qu
y a plus trop de paix 90
il n'y a plus trop de péno en vrai
joint à 9.1 il va jouer à neuf et demi
ou à 10
lors il a pas de bol d'or a fait
l'auteur mon temps parce qu'il y avait
une époque y aurait plus flotté mais
c'est et artemiev et la fée flotteurs
montant avec le troisième lots du groupe
pas de bol
pas de bol eu
un succès final avantage pas à mêler les
appariements c'est une formule
mathématique
ils peuvent pas avantager quelqu'un
donc n'y a pas de risque
il n'y a pas de qu'à ce niveau là
les vents en blanc ce serait cool ben
ouais mais ça c'est pas fou qu'il en
gagne 2 et après il pourra peut-être
joué les bons au blanc
mais tant qu'il fait pas de victoire ça
va être dur
il faut deux victoires
en fait je dirais que faut qu'ils
fassent à partir de maintenant tu entre
3 et 3 et demi sur quatre
et voir et voir où il en est après quoi
il ajouté
sinda rohff c'est un super appariement
c
et c'est pas facile hein il est il est
fort mais il est dangereux c'est une
petite housse bec
mais tu dois faire en fait
tu dois faire là au blanc sinndar of par
rapport au nombre de points qu'il a et
au fait qu'il soit en train de cravacher
pour remonter il doit gagner
là
bon truc au blanc
c'est une bonne occase pour remonter un
ilian et pokémon du boeuf 10 et demi
ma mère mam est remonté
wen ont cessé ce qui pouvait prendre de
mieux en fait ok là il a le beau lui il
faut à
il faut concrétiser
là il faut concrétiser là c'est le beau
lui
il faut prendre le pouls tôt
car sony joue guéri raivo blanc
[ __ ] des andes à il ya aussi qui en
masque un jusqu'à ce qu'il vienne
s'asseoir ces gens respectueux
maxime ces deux gars qui vont faire
gaffe c'est sûr
il bat c un fait mais je regarde vite
fait
ce qu'ils jouent pour essayer de
comprendre un peu la dynamique
bref les doubles qui joue martyrs au sûr
maintenant
des punto
faudrait que ça se tasse un peu de vent
tous peuvent tomber or martirossian à 10
ennemis c'est beau je veux partir au sur
c'est un bon joueur mais c'est toujours
faut toujours regarder qu'on
comparativement à t-on à ton classement
c'est beau quoi
par rapport à son la circulation dans le
tournoi c'est beau de jouer martirossian
fin c'est beau de faire fort fenac à
amine basset martirossian c'est
exceptionnel les appariements
avec ce nombre de points c'est
exceptionnel
bien sûr pareil un jouet martirossian
site à site à 6 sur 12 c'est un sale
appariement citadis et demi c'est un bel
appareil mais enfin ça dépend toujours
de ton score
dire et qui séparait de la table
vu qu'un j'en ai pas vu de deuxième
je vais aller tchèque
se faire tester en fait
arrive
les tests n'étaient pas obligatoires
pour jouer c'était vraiment que pour
prendre l'avion demain
après ce que j'ai compris sur son
twitter en fait c'était dans la même que
les gens qui devaient ce qui allait se
faire tester pour les fêtes demain
est un rêve de moroni sur l'e42 maugras
chess qui a dénoncé l'organisation de la
vie du coc vidya aucun test disponible
ni vérification des passes sanitaire
mais après ça ça fait longtemps ce
qu'alain
jeudi avant c'est un peu la strate
c'est un peu la strate
globalement
atteste patco vie d'un
tu
rates quoi
mais bon ça explique un peu les tweets
énervé de maxime sur d'autres sujets
aussi en vrai
c'est comme ça mais ça explique un peu
quelques tweets énervé de plusieurs
joueurs en fait
et après ça j'en sais rien mais c'est
allé trop de gens qui étaient avait trop
de joueurs top niveau qui était énervé
pour que ce soit juste juste comme ça
maxime prochaine maximum maxime
hyperimportant un conte sinndar off
et vu les retards des bus et il ya eu
pas mal de choses en vrai
mais on compte pas trop d'où vous venez
toute cette rage
à faire nul pas sur un
an
en trois minutes
contre quoi les joueurs des problèmes de
bus ya eu il
ya pas de détecteur de métaux il ya tout
un tas de petites choses mais mais en
fait ça doit être globalement très très
mal foutu
il ya eu plusieurs petits
petites choses mais du coup je compte je
commence à mieux comprendre en fait ça
doit être
le même niveau d'amateurisme à tous et à
toutes les échelles du tournoi donc
on doit voir que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
je crois il est hyper dangereux
il va falloir faire attention il est
très dangereux nouvelle fois je me
répète un petit peu mais quand on dit
symbole appariement ou genre il est papa
fort entre guillemets c'est il est pas
fort par rapport à ce que tu aurais pu
prendre
sales trucs
sortie c'est rouge à la coupe du monde
mais
il va falloir clic pour maxime
j'imagine une espagne enfin le quattro
en tout cas de nouveau
iq il faut cliquer pour maximale est
important de salles à aller ça là je
pense que
nul nul est quasi interdit ici
des fêtes des fêtes éliminatoires il va
falloir que maxime envoie les coups on
n'a pas les coups qui partent pour le
moment je vais voir caler le le problème
et ça l'a laissé bond à la petite
espagnole maxime qui joue la même
variante que contre
que compte ravine basset mais c'est une
espagnole ouverte qui est qui est décidé
par par sinndar off c'est une bonne
ouverture un dernièrement ça se joue au
noir ces trois pouces et 5 et b d2 il ya
même des variantes on peut prendre en f2
et donner les deux pièces contre la tour
et le pion
je ne sais pas si c'est ici ou pas en
tout cas maxime qui marque un petit
temps d'arrêt sur ce fou ces cinq peut
aussi avoir un coup comme dame de
impossible préparer le cavalier d2
alors on va voir on va voir comment il
commet il continue le français il a
mille cavaliers en d2 je crois que c'est
pas ici car lé problème de 6 à droite
ici match voyez je pensais que c'était
autre part mais c'est ici qui a valu à
vie de fou prend encore problème de m6
on avait vu une partie de maxime en
bundesliga dans cette variante contre
émane je crois parti que maxime avait
avait gagné avec les blancs mais c'est
pas évident comme variante
c'est une position
qui est paquet pas et qui n'est pas
évidente à jouer et sinda rohff a l'air
de bien connaître
en tout cas
les noirs ont pris deux pions
et une tour contre contre deux pièces
mineurs donc le matériel est plus ou
moins équivalent en milieu de jeu c'est
vrai que les pièces mineurs sont un peu
plus forts donc ça compense le fait
qu'ils aient deux pions maxime qui joue
cavalier ou trois je crois qu'ici c'est
fou aux six et il faut réussir un petit
peu à se gagner des cases peut-être part
à quatre baies 4 essayer de se placer
maxime qui a joué des trois ou quatre
cavaliers des quatre essais ça il faut
essayer de se gagner des cases et quand
je vous parle du dk c'est sûr des dames
prend du v4 sûr d'un point des quatre
dames des six b4 essayé après de mettre
le fou en b2 maxime qui joue avec ses
des dames f6 attention à la dame qui
veut rentrer sur f2 il va falloir jouer
d'amd de ici maxime est pas forcément
super bien son adversaire a l'air de
mieux connaître la position d'amd de
jouer maxime qui veut x 3 maintenant et
tour f1 le fion qui vient en c5 ça c'est
peut-être une faute c'est 5 c 4
dc b c et maxime va peut-être réussir à
replacer son fou vers 5 aussi le fou de
maxime arrivant aux cinq ce serait
extraordinaire allez mon maxime le fou
qui vient en a trois ça c'est pas mal
j'aurais peut-être dû échanger une fois
avant mais il veut il veut food et 6
maxime il veut food et 6
pensent qu'il a le fou des 6 es fou aux
cinq sa part est vraiment intéressant de
venir faire ce cadrage débordement avec
le fouet se placer devant la structure
et de m'élancer 5 c'est pas bête non
plus hein il est beaucoup mieux et tient
là casey's est fluide ce fou et du coup
il permet de colmater la colonne f et il
n'y a pas de colonne ouverte sur sur
pions préemption prend il y aura pas de
colonne c est ici il va falloir
réfléchir à ce qu'on joue avec les
blancs est ce qu'on peut même se
permettre 1 h 4 je ne pense pas h3 on
n'a pas forcément envie parce que ça
donne du fou proches 3 dans le règne
donc il fait tour f1 dame g6 ton point
f7 c'est hyper logique il échange une
paire de tours et maintenant il va
falloir la travailler au corps celle là
est ce que maxime va même envoyé un dame
f2 pour échanger les dames je pense pas
il doit vouloir tenter de faire du taf
avec avec les dames mais c'est pas si
évident que ça parce que la dame noire
pourrait venir s'infiltrer sur quasiment
le fou de cases noires et fort un ebook
les colonnes ouverte mais d'un autre
côté ils participent aux jo a le droit
il joue il joue d'un f2 d'un problème de
prise f2 il va falloir regarder aussi
les tours france et 5 comprend ces cinq
des quatre mais on pourrait prendre le
cas depuis reprendront eux trois et on
pourrait récupérer les pions avoir une
bonne position plus qu'une 28 pour
maxime contre 2,27 pour pour sinndar of
le joueur ouzbek qui a réussi à jouer
vite et qui maintenant doivent vraiment
calculs et on prend ces cinq à mon avis
qui on prend ces 5 et d4 c'est assez
tentant pions préemption prend fou prend
1,4 comprend le droit d'en prendre trois
qu'est ce que donne cette position c'est
difficile à dire mais le x 1 4 de maxime
dans la position résultante serait
vraiment puissant et contrôlerait
énormément de cases sur l'échiquier a
laissé bien sinndar off qui est en train
d'un petit peu temps qu'est et de
d'enfants à réfléchir dans cette
position ça va aussi donner le temps à
maxime de s'organiser le joueur ouzbek
le jeune joueur ouzbek même qui doit
vraiment se focaliser sur le tour prend
ces cinq pays il décide de jouer tout
retour c7 et maxime qui envoie d'alger 3
tempo et maintenant on va pouvoir
commencer à faire h3 se donner un petit
peu d'air avec le roi et peut-être même
réussir à naviguer le fou pour rentrer
et ce que maxime va maintenant partir
avec son fou vers la casse d un il
commence par h3 ça ça vous qu'on a envie
de faire depuis un long moment ça enlève
un petit peu descazeaux fou de deux
cases blanches il s'adonne une case aux
aurois de repli les noirs qui joue
autour des 7 peut-être la dame peut
rentrer sur cinq maintenant pour aller
jouer ces cases noires il fait fou d1 et
ce qui va partir pour fou g4 c'est une
possibilité même si ce fou est un
mauvais fou ça peut donner car allégé
quatre cavaliers ou cinq on peut aussi
vouloir jouer cavalier j 4 direct et et
jouer là la paire de fois attention à ce
pion sait qu'il faudra surveiller comme
le lait sur le feu qui relie j4 semble
être un coup vraiment intéressant il est
joué par maxime fou pranger quatre fous
pranger 4 l'ordinateur donne maintenant
un immense avantage pour les noirs mais
je pense que l'ordinateur se trompe
complètement d'ailleurs dame g5 remet
les blancs à flot est ce que maxime va
jouer 1 h 4 ici est d'alger 5 est quand
même bien joué 1 puisque mais ils
empêchent cave a lieu cinq peut-être
dames 5 ici pour maxime mais attention
hein quand il y aura plus les dames faut
vraiment que le roi cours en 3
rapidement pour gérer les pions allèles
d'am-dam 5 qui est jouée sur coup franc
j'ai quatre dames pranger 5 qui ont
projet 5-fu pranger 4 la position semble
excellente
pour maxime maxime qui est en train de
faire un énorme travail dans cette
partie il cravache 1 pour revenir dans
le tournoi et garder ses chances de
devenir champion du monde en vie c'est
plutôt bien joué le da racing kodak
prend 1,5 y avait les prochains que ça
va partir fou pranger cadre d'un projet
5 sinndar off qui est en train de
tanguer sévèrement du temps on va
revenir à 50 secondes chacun et c'est là
que le joueur français brille
généralement d'alger 6 allée l'ordi
dunban en gagnant après terme des huit
cavaliers au sac d'un v8 cavaliers 5
c'est une cale aller maxime il faut le
voir c'est pas si facile à trouver c'est
un décalage call décalage de deux
maximes pour libérer la case du cavalier
il est pas simple dame b 8 allée maxime
il faut qu'il ait cette tactique en jeu
quand il est en forme il le voit
instantanément à l'efo décalé où il l'a
pas il l'a pas il l'a pas les amis s'ils
avaient ils auraient déjà loués sylla il
là il la halle et maxime cavaliers 5 il
décale il fait une fourchette maintenant
il va avoir une pièce de plus il va pas
falloir se faire prendre comme contrat
mine basse m il va falloir la mener au
bout cette position est une nouvelle
fois il a pas de volume maxime il n'a
pas la chance avec lui parce que la
position reste quoi qu'il en soit c'est
dangereux ça aurait pu être complètement
terminée déjà il va falloir encore
cravacher peut-être ramener la dame
angers 3 en défense au dam des deux un
bon coup joué par par sinndar of
peut-être que le fonds peut partir en h5
il faut aller à les attaquer le roi dame
5 j'ai pas compris le coup il veut quoi
sur dame prend d un il veut quelque
chose il veut fouet fuite au 7 mars ou
des andes fouet fuite pour aller mater
son adversaire en force qu'est ce que
c'est bien joué foudroyage trois
meilleurs coups joués par sinndar off
qui trouve les coûts hélas il n'a pas de
beau lui maxime une nouvelle fois parce
que les pions sont dangereux c'est
incroyable maxime qui se bat contre tous
le dieu des échecs et contre lui
mesdames prend des 5 c'est encore l'air
d'aller d'un machin est encore droit
j'ai trois dames un airois f4 ça devrait
le faire quand même la dame qui en train
d'intervenir le pion aux 4 qui peut être
perdu sur échec et le fou qui va pouvoir
revenir on a trois pour gérer mais
attention il ya aussi un pion passé qui
peut qui peut se présenter de l'autre
côté de l'échiquier ya eu dames 5 il
contrôle le pion aux oeufs pour le
moment sur sur deux il y aura peut-être
des simply food et 4 pour aller jouer le
match mais attention à ne pas prendre
une marée de pions passé qui pourrait
faire mal c'est complexe la position
n'est pas encore terminée sinndar off
encore plus d'un tour dans son sac
maxime qui envoie le foin f8 dame g6 va
être forcé dames 3e 2 maxime qui
commence à gérer les pions n'y a pas
d'âme des six échecs mais y en a encore
un qui part il y en a de partout de ses
pions on n'en peut plus aller le fonds a
trois qui va revenir en c1 maxime qui
valait le gérer c'est terrible c'est
terrible les amis ouais ça y est fou et
le fou qu'il y en a trois la dame qui
revient à maxime qui va gérer ce pion
gentiment peut-être qu'il va il va
mettre le fou en b2 dame f3 puis on
prenait 3 attention il va y avoir des
pions passées à gérer de partout non la
dame qui revient ans et 8 peut-être des
5 pouces et un maintenant peut-être des
5 pouces et un fall envoyé ce pion dam
des trois échecs il chasse le roi a et
peut-être qu'il a même le beau lui
d'avoir dû c'est un des six des sept
dames c'est cette g3 d'amd 8 il a dû
calculer jusqu'au bout maxime c1 ne doit
pas passer on lui fait confiance il faut
penser à un français en dame des 5 ouais
c'est pas si simple quand même 17 tams
et 7 le la dame revient en des 8 es ce
que maxime aurait pas pêché par
gourmandise dams et c'est 3-3 dam des
huit dames f5 mois salir gagnant tout de
même mais c'est pas fini fini bon même
maxime ne peut plus perdre mais c'est
vrai qu'il a dû être au et d'amd cinq
échecs ça y est c'est terminé s'est
terminée d'amd 8 la gamme de trop dam
des cinq échecs et des huit dames maxime
est de retour maxime est de retour mais
il a dû se faire un petit peu peur après
la partie perdue contre amine bassem
dans une situation équivalente ça a dû
lui rappeler les démons diarrhée magnus
carlsen qui s'incline contre à nice
guérie au magnus carlsen pourrait perdre
deux de ses trois titres de champion du
monde cette année plus aussi dominateur
qu'auparavant magnus s'incline contre le
gastronome anish giri ouais c'est un
tremblement de terre ici pour pour l'ex
ce triple champion du monde j'ai envie
de dire qui est en train de perdre ses
titres 1 les uns après les autres ouais
il ya eu quoi comme comme autres
résultats nepomniachi les bons ça a fait
nul et yao ni choquant corps qui jouent
contre ali reza et alireza qui va lui
aussi revenir dans le tournoi il a l'air
d'être gagnants
incroyable cette année je guéris
incroyable anish giri qui se relance
enfin qui se relance qui était déjà bien
dans le tournoi mais qui relance
complètement le tournoi maxime va
maintenant être devant un magnus carlsen
magnus carlsen dans le rétro du numéro
un français tu cherches magnus
non je le cherchais mon arrivée il est
là il est là il est là on le on le
trouve
il est la magnus il est encore là
ali reza qui va rejoindre magnus
d'ailleurs et maxime qui se replacent
complètement dans ce championnat du
monde il n'a pas dit son dernier mot
il dit denise la swde comme disent les
américains pour
faire un peu les commentaires bilingue
nice qui l'emportent contre magnus on
sait qu'il aime bien jouer magnus aniche
rap est content avec magnus d'israël
machart matches championnat du monde je
ne pourrais que contredit rouge a
peut-être mais il faut gagner quand même
contre les anciens contre sa génération
et l'ani tout est mal
alors que j'ai fait j'ai rien fait de
grave
martirossian qui prend un maître du
couloir assez terrible
ça peut être un problème en fête du
boeuf parce qu'il a la baraka
j'aime pas quand des joueurs ont la
baraka ça me fait toujours peur jean
très chanceux me font peur aux échecs
trop de baraka et dangereux
ce cas maxime qui revient proche des
leaders avec ça
à
je suis en train de chercher cette
partie mais d'où bof ça dégoûte un
bon après il était meilleur
pas mieux du tout
ainsi les teigneux
il était mérité mieux
bon
ça va pas maximin
il se replace
là il s'est bien passé il s'est bien
replacé
là il sait bien
prochaine
enfin tout est important
mais bon c'est le fait qu'il ait gagné
ça la salle-
ça lance vraiment dans la journée bon
apparemment
de boeuf neuf fois les blancs sur
combien de partis
rice elle compte un cas où ils allaient
noire elle va compter en plus
neuf fois sur 15 c'est énorme
c'est énorme
le bo lui le beau lui est impressionnant
pour le moment pour dubois fumée a
tellement besoin de chance en ans les
tournois quand même comme ça tournoi
suisse tellement de variance
avec maxime double et blanc il a doublé
les noirs aujourd'hui
naka elle compte
donc 9 sur 15
ha mais en fait il n'a pas joué la
première il était forfait mais il devait
avoir les noirs façon ça changera
9 sur 15 c'est énorme
ça c'est un bol incroyable
mais bon alors que maxime va sûrement
jouer au blanc
donc ça peut être
nouvelle pour nous en vrai
que s'ils jouent maxi maxime sera au
blanc c'est sûr
à voir même les triplés way
normalement
maximas est blanc 8 noir wen ans elle
al'avantage ça c'est que si maxime joue
du golfe c'est sûr qu'il double blanc
et il peut finir par le jouet et
ouais ouais non non il est pas
maximaliser il est dans le bon groupe à
il va être dans le groupe 10 ennemis à
11 il va y avoir quelques gars
ils vont même pas être très nombreux à
11 10 il a fait quoi un match où
il ya deux gars vraiment devant c'est ça
qui est chiant c'est qu'ils adouberaient
fait
il ya deux gars vraiment devant
et maximin mauvaise a pareillement un
mauvais
départage mais il doit pas avoir un il
va pas avoir un si mauvais départage
façade ou pas puisque double à jouer et
contrit chaos et hikaru va pas mettre
beaucoup de points
[ __ ] à m koudrine tôt
donc si maxime
s'il gagne la prochaine au noir
las il fait deux sur trois en fait peu
vrai il reste moins de partir et si
partie offert 5 sur 6
c'est tendu
après ce classement il est tellement
faux que c'est pour ça que je vous
demande pas trop parce qu'en fait
il manque des joueurs en fait non dans
maxim et bien 9e non non il est juste la
magnus il fait flotteurs ça peut pas
être sûr maxime tant que maxime reste
devant magnus il peut pas flotter mais
magnus quel beau lui aussi de rester
tableau 1 tout le temps c'est vraiment
terrible
mais là encore les noirs normes et c'est
c'est pas possible c'est en fait
mais là vraiment encore les noirs faut
agir tu vas faire et douvres a fait
encore voir les blancs ou c ou la blague
s'arrête non mais bon bah tu prends un
double of il va avoir quatre fois plus
les blancs que maxime face et n'importe
quoi c'est terrible allez faut se battre
comme gisèle avantage c'est qu'après il
peut jouer blanc il va redoubler blanc
compte du golfe
en attendant ils jouent pas un joueur
trop fort il vous martine kraft 6
ça se gagne pas la fin et non non non le
c'est un système suisse avec autant de
joueurs c'est un peu la merde
alors
suite c'est normal
c'est normal alors qu'ils prennent noir
mais c'est pas beau c'est bien de
prendre noir contre lui en fait s'il
prend noir c'est le bon moment c'est
plutôt fait vaut mieux jouer crash 6
quand même là ça va en vrai ça va
en vraie sarah
du golfe abusé mais c'est le seul en
fait
safari suite
s'ils gagnent celle là il se replace
complètement
il a 12 le classement il est pas vrai en
fait alors classement de chasse comme
c'est
ok regagné aux noirs ici
skerrit galicie double offs à peu fermé
il peut vraiment remonter la
hague riccio karl scène intéressant
aussi green shoots gagne il va avoir
super envie de gagner il élimine
complètement car la scène
ewan plus besoin de prendre de risques
pas sûr puisque si les bonnes fées nul
il va se retrouver à douze ennemis
maxime gagne il se retrouvera aux
ennemis et maxime il colle à l'événement
prairie
l'adversaire de double file et dangereux
aussi
paraît il suffit de dire i bat les vents
et guiry et à 12 ans vrai hein
il reste bien deux parties aujourd'hui
on avait neuf c'est ça
on a joué trois il en reste six
ça peut le faire encore pour maxime
sept ans ils réussiront non
reste à rendre 16 17 18 19 20 21 et six
rondes
un point c'est rien super une partie
contre un gars un point derrière toi
c'est fini
après le tie-break de maxime est très
mauvais mais il a joué vraiment que des
plots maxime ça le problème
pas tant que ça en vrai
ouais maxime mamaï ne veut pas décaler
les tables il restait tableur
et maxime il peut récupérer du
départagent pas ce qu'il va jouer les
premiers mais les autres aussi est ce
qu'il est si vendée partage
il a vraiment un départage de mervent
il a joué qui fait d'autres forains
simon départage
c'est n'importe quoi fedoseyev il a joué
tout le monde en fait
fait d'offre s'il fait date si je vous
tout le monde en fait pour un fait aussi
fait un tournoi de malade 1 ils jouent
tous dallas encore avait fait d'os
fellows faut qu'ils perdent en fait
c'est terrible
il n'y a pas
quelqu'un nous a dit que si le joueur
que tu as pas joué
il est sorti du tournoi ils font un truc
sais pas comment
j'espère que ça compte un de toute façon
un gars comme tout boeuf qui a gagné par
forfait c'est pas normal que ça lui
donne un monde et partagent aussi un
tellement un gros avantage de gaming pas
une game par forfait
encore ce qu'ils ont joués et qu'ils ont
joué à la loyale c'est une chose mais
celui qui gagne par forfait
mais en ce qu'ils ont en fait c'est une
chose mais
le royal sans aucun souci mais d'où oif
en plus il sent plus ça lui donne un bon
départage c'est vraiment
neuf fois les blancs forfait pont des
partages français boit le calice jusqu'à
la lie qu'autant lui donne le titre de
champion du monde et on joue la deuxième
place 1
qui est encore son ex-agent prével
bazoumana bailly défaite interdite pour
maxime l'a fait il peut plus perdre là
nul ça va m'aider fait est grave
un numéro en premier aux vélos blitz non
mais ça sert à quoi tu vas finir
centièmes du championnat du monde et tu
vas être un premier où il habite le
hello c'est vraiment mal foutu
c'est important la deûle à yannis hâlas
sylla noire celle là
en fait disent on s'y perd elle encore
chances de podium s'il fait nul
il reste en vie s'ils gagnent
ça commence à devenir intéressant
ça commence on se rend en trois minutes
fear ou s il gagne tout ça peut le faire
aussi
en falsifiant gagne la prochaine il
revient à onze et il se remet dedans un
après la difficulté pour les français
c'est comme ils n'ont pas joué contre
d'autres fort joueur entre guillemets
et peule à rester du monde à jouer pour
ça serait pas mal que great schuepbach
carlson pour éloigner vraiment vraiment
magnus
essayer de continuer déjà en évitant
magnus et en jouant les autres candidats
directs
maxime
sorti une grosse game
là c'est un peu comme contre guy en fait
si grave si tu fais rien faut prendre là
nul c'est pas grave et on joue la
prochaine avec les blancs et c'est une
opportunité jouer une partie d'échecs et
enfin rien qu'on ne se pose chez pas si
les cyclos que ça je connais pas le
level de platitude de kraft fils
j'imagine que c'est un plot mais
[Musique]
martin fra 6
nés en 90 il est même pas jeune quoi
ouais clairement c'est un plot un très
très clairement way va falloir faire
parler la poudre martin romanovitch
crysis est un joueur d'échecs ukrainien
et le 26 novembre 1990 à lviv
alors mon avis
biographie bon
champion d'ukraine
talent est premier ex-aequo au machin
voilà rien gagné un
café une coupe du monde il a été éliminé
au premier tour enfin
ces personnes
moins connue car yann tahri
champions n'est pas champion de russie
je croyais champions de rien du tout
champion de russie il est même pas russe
quand tu veux qu'ils soient champions de
russie qu'est ce qu'il faut pas lire
dans le chatt
procès un péno
allez faut marquer le péno ici au noir
allez petit sicilienne maxime qui va
envoyer la nage dorff
non food et cinq échecs ça pleut trees
côté côté ukrainien
allez faut aller le chercher
ça va jouer les taux de maroc si ça va
pas prendre de risques et je vous dis
tout de suite ça va mettre du barbelé
côté ukrainien
et c6 g6 rouge et 7
mais bon ça va envoyer du des cuatro et
taux de barouk si
ça va être solide pour les blancs mais
ça peut ça peut tourner maxime joue bien
ses positions allez mon max
là c'est quand même une opportunité en
or
que de jouer contre martin martin avec
un y j'suis pas si on l'appelle par
rappellerai pas plutôt martine aubry
vont envoyer le des cuatro ici c'est sûr
et on va avoir les taux maxime qui va
devoir tenter de jouer avec 6 assists b5
voici vous aussi ce dessin qu il va
avoir toutes les cases noires maxime et
prend des quatre fous g7 je sais pas
pourquoi il a tant que autant de temps
martin sur le dé quattro mais on prend
on prend le tiempo on prend le tiempo
pour maxime au noir il a une belle
position
il a une belle position le français non
mais je vais je vais mettre les bons
mots à gauche pour que les nouveaux ne
soient pas surpris
c max donc au noir pour être bien sûr
donc il a le fou angers7 je sais pas
trop ce qui fait martine honnêtement
comprends pas pourquoi ils tant qu après
après fou g7
mais s'attend que s'attend que sévère je
vais mettre un petit refresh pour être
bien sûr je ne suis pas bien sûr ça
tangue trop
en a je vais l'ouvrir l'échiquier je
comprends pas ça c'est pas la bonne
partie
il attend qu'une minute pour rien on a
été obligés de vérifier on ne comprend
pas donc et prend des quatre fous g7 il
attend que pour cavaliers eu de
terribles
allez faut que maxime eux trouvent les
coûts rock a6b 5 c'est le plan classique
aller sa part une minute d'avant ce
manque d'expérience ce côté ukrainien
face à un tel requins comme maxime il ne
faut pas se mettre mal autant il va en
payer les frais vous allez voir
tant qu'unique dans l'ouverture sur les
coûts les plus évidents c'est un petit
peu trop
il faut envoyer peut-être le betting
cola qui part avec la tour qui arrive en
baie vitrée il ya tout petits qui
s'allument il fait cavalier 5 ça a l'air
d'être encore meilleur et b3 il peut y
avoir du betting cauet s'est joué par
maxime le pion b5 et défendu a laissé
une superbe ouverture là au noir c'est
parfait les amis c'est parfait c'est la
position qu'on rêvait d'avoir qui est
des cinq c'est bien joué ils menacent
cavaliers caraïbes et cissé sur
cavaliers prend il veut reprendre de ses
maximes va probablement décalé saddam
sur bessette jouer un coup en coûts de
tours je pense qu'il ya plutôt décalé en
fait parce que tour des huit on n'a pas
super envie on va plus envie de mettre
une dame en baisse pour ses huit tours b
8 il joue dame b cette maxime deux
minutes on te montre une 40
lenny kravitz avec avec les blancs qui
eux
qui en danger un l'option c4 est attaqué
sur pions prend qu on prend ça va ouvrir
la colonne carré les problèmes si ce fou
prend f6 il peut y avoir des découvertes
puis on prend qui on prend et b4 pour
aller fixer le pion à 2 allée tour c'est
un bcbc tours tours b 8 tours c'est 8
regardez ça va partir avec les tours sur
les colonnes ça semble plus agréable à
jouer maintenant pour les noirs même
s'il a probablement pas davantage ça
semble commencer à bien se passer
cavalier b6 intermédiares oh ça c'est un
bon coup j'avais pas vu il veut jouer
tour avait 8 qui avait laissé quatre il
veut maintenir maintenir l'égalité est
ce que maxime va avoir du dessine qu
enfin deux variantes il fait tour des
8es où ils préparent des simcoe maxime
attention car l epr en cavale et prend
il va devoir jouer les pions prend le
joueur ukrainien mais il aura gagné un
petit tempo sur le tour c'est 8 mai il
va y avoir du cavalier 17 au il prend du
pion il est gourmand il est gourmand
il est gourmand il veut se garder le
cavalier en b 6 maxime qui essayent
d'immobiliser ce cavalier pas de pas de
ticket de sortie entrée gratuite sortie
payante pour le cavalier b6 qui va
peut-être devoir aller faire les
bordures allèles en 1/4 et la dame qui
va revenir ans et 6 maxime qui a une
position à l'est c'est maintenant c'est
maintenant qu'il faut produire l'effort
il peut peut-être partir sur du dessin
qui est tout ouvrir ses dépositions dans
lesquels maxime est absolument
redoutable c'est le meilleur joueur du
monde dans ses positions allez mon petit
il va falloir aller lui ouvrir la
tronche lui ouvrir le centre il fait
qu'il y ait des scènes plus tranquilles
il doit avoir une morale août rien sur
qui les prend 17 cents lits des arrivées
comprend 17 et préparer tout d'abord en
bd 6 jouer instantanément mais là il ya
peut-être cavaliers b huit cavaliers c6
jouer je crois qu'il a raté d'un
prendrait six honnêtement je pense qu'il
l'a raté
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe maxime
est pas à 100% et qui a aidé cette
c'était faible comme coup à mon avis
était faible mais bon la position reste
complexe il va falloir
continuer à mettre la pression peut-être
tour ses huit tours b1 damas huit à les
cacher la dame est joué pour du cavalier
des 4 je pense qu'il va mettre la dame
en a huit allées bien placé attention
hein kravitz qui ont quand même en sueur
il ya du cavalier 5 qui menaçait du
cavalier des quatre plus de 18 secondes
maxime qui a toujours été ma peau il a
peut-être pas joué les coups les plus
précis mais il fait mal et il fait même
très très mal maxime ça commence à être
mal autant de cavaliers mme veil qui va
jaillir verser 4 maxime qui va peut-être
la gagner maxime qui est bien le
cavalier qui arrive en c4 allez mon
grand il va y avoir dams est inquiet
prendre trois d'entre eux trois il va
falloir récupérer ce pion avec du dames
c'est 62.4 peut-être maxime qui est plus
très loin maintenant de prendre un
avantage qui peut être décisif surtout
que lénine a plus que tu es martin plus
tôt n'a plus de 15 secondes il ya
peut-être tourné trois ans nous dit dans
le chatt tour des trois dames c est
malheureusement ça ne mène pas à grand
chose mes cavaliers c4 prise de troie et
dams et si ça a l'air assez cool on va
voir si c'est ce qu'ils jouent il fait
trois tours détroit il va faire dame c6
maintenant c'est sûr ça doit être son
idée il ya peut-être fouet fuite aussi
dames cécile va récupérer le le pion à 4
maxime qui va servir
maxime qui va servir qui égalise
matériellement il va remettre la dame
ans et cissé va maintenant essayer de
faire le taf sur le pion c5 attention un
plus que 56
55 secondes pour maxime 17 secondes pour
son adversaire attention peut-être
déclaré l'épreuve trois qui peuvent
freiner la tour qui vient on à deux il
vient couvrir le cavalier maintenant il
va falloir que maxime réussissent à
mettre la pression sur sur le pion c5
qui avait laissé six très bien joué il
empêche tourbe et de son fou g7 qui
brille là toutes les cases orolia du
cavalier b4 qui traîne il ya du cavalier
b4 très puissant ici la tour n'a presque
plus de cases d'amd un maxime qui est
pas loin là il n'est pas loin de faire
quelque chose mais peut-être tour des
huit maintenant pour aller chasser une
nouvelle fois cette dame et cavaliers b4
qui arrive dans maxim qui fait à cinq
cavaliers c'est un détour qui vient en
b1 il vient clouer la torah de est très
mal placé est-ce que la finale gagne
après 1.4.4 tour b 4 c'est une vraie
question
ou est-ce que maxime a simplement joué
damas six il hésite plus de 30 secondes
il faut pas la rater celle là c'est une
occasion en or c'est le golden goal les
amis la tour qui vend des huit fouet 3
il faut réussir à mettre la marche avant
avec avec ce pion à le pion à qui est
proche qui est proche proche proche d'
aller à dame ainsi réussi à débloquer la
situation maxime ça va pousser ils
échangent toutes les pièces il menace
pour penser à eux maintenant j'aime pas
trop ces échanges mais eux mais
maintenant c'est fait c'est fait et le
pion à 5 est quand même plus fort il va
t'on point f1 et et ramener le roi c'est
pas sûr qu'il la gagne ce serait dommage
de la rate et tourbe et trois non il n'a
pas échangé tour ces trois la tour
blanche avenir en d1 et le pion qui va
avancer oh non ça va être nul les amis
ou pas il ya quatre contre quatre à
l'est le royal pion à 5 passes et la
tour qui passe derrière et maxime qui a
peut-être pas pris assez de risques dans
cette partie bon ça peut suffire l'
avantage c'est que c'est du jeu et de
résultats peut-être la tour peut venir
en b2 et et on a deux se fixer derrière
les le pion à plus de 27 secondes contre
dix c'est chaud pour tout le monde la
tour qui viendra trois leroy qui va
monter maxime qui va pousser gentiment
les pions ce qui va réussir à la gagner
cela elle doit objectivement être nul je
pense
mais il peut le faire prise prise
droit qui va venir en aide deux noms il
fait aux 5 maxime qui va monter le roi
angers 6 et ce qui peut pousser son pion
et pousser l'effort jusqu'au bout le
pion qui vient angers 4 le roi qui est
qui est bloqué pour le moment il réussit
pas à s'activer
mais les blancs qui vont être obligés
d'aller cacher le roi en a deux et à
maxime va pouvoir monter non il peut pas
monter le roi claustrophobie aide il
peut peut-être faire un lifting co par
contre peut-être faire un f6 3g 6 il va
pouvoir monter en haut 5 mètres l'option
à deux mètres l'euro f4 m le rend
heureux 3 et il va gagner avec trois
dents ça doit gagner il va faire à deux
maintenant maxime
il va faire à deux le roi qui va avoir
la case 3 ça devrait le faire les amis
ça devrait le faire
pour pour le joueur français parce que
le roi peut monter
il va faire à deux maintenant
il va devoir faire à deux maintenant
c'est pas sûr qu'elle soit gagnante en
fait
c'est pas sûr qu'elle soit gagnante oh
non c'est terrible
c'est terrible
pour b à 5
assez terrible
c'est terrible je crois que ça gagne pas
les amis
il va y avoir du f3 trop qui va partir
ou pas maxime qui monte quand même le
roi il a peut-être 3b 4,3 et 4,4 kg on
prend non ça va peut-être gagné tour
j'ai trois mois c'est pas loin
c'est pas loin du tout il va pouvoir
cacher le roi
peut-être que c'est drouot tempo près
cette histoire
à l option est l'option jécistes gène
assez incroyable
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable ce
qu'ils ratent maxime
ouais mais bon
bah non c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'était total gagnant est
c'était totalement gagnant
c'est sûr qu'il pouvait faire mieux
au retour des huit dames 1 qui avait les
b 4 f
c'est sûr qu'ils pouvaient faire mille
fois mieux
sûr que c'était fallait pas rentrer dans
la finale fait jouer un truc comme ça
est mille fois plus fort avec le pion à
qui paraît tout
et même là
même là lavez la gagnante
sachant pas quand il défend si tu fais à
deux rois g2 f6 si on prend un pion
prend
pour à 5 recettes tu peux pas
va te faire les échecs par là bas
tu peux pas gagner comme ça non
à cette terrible
tiens ça se sentait qu'elle était dans
l'air
terrible à
sinon c'est quoi duda qui a battu fait
d'os c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
grille choo qui a battu magnus web qui
va rester comme tableau 1 mais
magnus magnus est loin
ça va être dur dans la tête en plus
ali reza qui a perdu contre macho glue
alireza c'est complètement finie
c'est le manque de confiance il à la
partie contre amine lui fait beaucoup de
mal en fait
c'est terrible
c'est pour le podium c'est pas fini
encore
il reste qu il reste cinq parties
à ça
rami n'en fait ira-t-il rate la partie
qui peut tellement bien le maître
après pour le podium c'est loin d'être
fini même pour la première place est
encore une petite chance mais c'est plus
le scénario une nouvelle fois qui est
embêtant
parce qu'ils vont 13 points simmons
faire cinq sur cinq ans quatre et demi
quatre emmy sur cinq s'est jusque là il
avait une belle occase c'est le truc
cité okaz quand tu es derrière faut pas
les rater normalement
je sens qu'il n'y aura pas passifs et
cinq sur cinq c'est qu'ils balle est
bonne donc si fait cinq sur cinq il est
pas mal mais bon
mais karl c'est non il est pas bien il
sera pas champion du monde de blitz ce
soir il aura plus qu'un titre un magnus
les américains qui vont rafler un titre
de champion du monde pas par
l'intermédiaire du chaos
non
il soutient la prochaine
joue les bonnes
ils jouent les vannes
c'est de récupérer la cam
ok bon là c'est victor obinna y'a pas à
tortiller série gagne il se relance
s'ils gagnent pas s'est terminée en fait
c'est aussi simple que ça en fait
lacam peut tout faire buggé
est ce que est ce que est ce que ça te
fait bugger non
chez pac la cam 1 donc
on verra mais ça peut faire bugger je
relancerai au cas où ça bug
dubois fille là encore les blancs
j'appelle encore les blancs c'est
incroyable ah oui là encore aller blanc
mais qu'ont ils fait pour avoir autant
de fois les blancs
correctement honnêtement la cie gagne
contre les bonnes oui
comment il fait pour encore avoir les
blancs
il a eu une deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit blanc et un deux trois quatre
cinq
et sept ans ils recommencent à avoir les
blancs
mais comment il fait pour autant de fois
les blancs
haxhi millet et en vrai s'ils gagnent
celle là il est vraiment temps encore un
cif et cinq sur cinq en fait c'est sûr
que c'est bon
sympa
peut-être quatre et demi suffi 1
4 me sur 5 il fait ainsi baronia n'en
fait quatre et demi ça peut largement
suffire
bon c'est une partie hyper importante un
jeu
s'est rajouté les calmes
que j'ai ça peu buggé à chaque fois que
je rajoute un ca doit ça doit mettre un
temps mort quand je le fais
ça va bug quelques secondes
normalement
normalement ça doit être revenu
à voir si on a la cam
normalement ses revenus sa facture
quelques secondes
va voir si là aussi c'est une autre
il peut le faire si main
il est là il a l'air déterminé maxime
victoire obligatoire là pour la peine
si tu fais nul ses dadas
m de dubaï
ça c'est la cam de magnus avant il faut
que je rajoute les deux autres j'ai pas
j'ai pas la bonne came ça va refaire un
petit bug
normalement ça doit refaire un petit bug
caméra doit apparaître
paraître
sama chat
sur soi cela est facilement rescue n'a
rien n'a que quatre
on va voir est ce qu'on n'a pas la table
2 1 quoique ces deux là n'en qui est
écrit
non
c'est 1,5 pour la table 5
c'est complètement con
je vois la dernière que j'ai savard
buggé par contre
si le stream scoop ça revient rapidement
va vous dire qu'en par contre
couillard
non je vais avoir tout les calmes sauf
celle de maxime
il ya la table 5 mis à part la table 2
non j'ai une bêtise il me reste une
encore
peut-être le guern
une nouvelle fois sa peu buggé
on va voir si ça a buggé ou pas et si ça
marche
non c'est bon c'est la dernière
la chance
la chance des amis
champ cède
champ cède les amis le ministre est de
retour pour la fin du tournoi allez le
ministre
ah ça fait plaisir de voir mourir je
vous avais dit que maxime allait mettre
le masque pas c'est juste quelqu'un de
très respectueux maxime quand je disais
c'est quelqu'un de très gentil et très
respectueux
maxime qui pensent à autrui
ça c'est pas étonnant
et ça ce n'est pas étonnant
comment ne pas être pour ce joueur les
amis
c'est difficile de pas être pour maxime
en fait c'est vraiment difficile
il donne il donne un bon exemple c'est
vraiment vraiment quelqu'un de bien en
fait injuste
terrible trop gentil safari fille qui
est vrai mais ce qu'il vaut mieux pas
être quelqu'un de gentil au final même
si ça te coûte des titres de champion du
monde ou et
franchement je préfère je peux faire a
largement avoir un maxime
c'est quelqu'un vraiment extraordinaire
on l'a la caméra
il s'adresse à main c'est possible si
son adversaire lui serre la main il
serre la main aussi à mon avis je pense
qu'il va serrer la main allez bonne
voie pas maxime refusant serrage de main
si son adversaire
l'imi 6
maxime par contre il va enlever son
masque je pense pendant la partie pour
pouvoir être concentré à 100% bien
évidemment
pas il peut pas se pénaliser à mon avis
autant que ça par rapport aux autres
a laissé la partie importante il le sait
maxime
il le sait maxime c'est la partie
décisive s'il veut remonter dans ce
tournoi c'est maintenant il a l'air
déterminé à faire le boulot
c'est qu'on le regarde bien évidemment
il sait qu'on est là derrière lui
il sait qu'on est fond
on espère tellement le voir gagner et
remonter dans ce tournoi
c'est le moment ou jamais oui je vais
allumer la lumière histoire de bien tout
voir
cette partie ci gagne celle là qui se
donne un petit un petit bonus en plus
par rapport aux autres
allez faut lui envoyer l'énergie ouais
faut lui envoyer notre énergie
espérait
on pourra pas faire beaucoup plus allez
il faut mettre le couteau ça va arriver
côté les bons au dernier moment
maxime qui lui tend la main quand même
et qui repart pour la game c'est ce que
je vous disais c'est est sûre
ça c'était sûr aussi je le connais
maxime j'avais anticipé
envoyée
allez maxime
allais il envoie salle ils envoient au
quattro e singh au cavalière tron va
partir sur une espagnole
ça va partir sur une espagnole les amis
ils les connaissent et espagnol maxime
leeuwen aussi les ventes en grande forme
annonce sournois leader de points
d'avancé sur maxime un point d'avancé
sur la meute il joue fous ces cinq
variantes variant de quatre chefs tu
allais à quatre ses trois as et là c'est
la grande c'est la très grande variante
donc les noirs ne peuvent pas vraiment
ici encaissé le pion aux cartes ra ya
toujours fous des cinq importants à 5 x
7 ça doit répéter une partie caruana mvl
non par mdl caruana plus tôt donc le
foot il y en a sept
et il va jouer peut-être fou j'estime
qu'au
qui sait où fouet 3 il met le feu 3 les
bonnes qui se concentre
alors est ce que les bonnes va envoyer
fou g4 et je crois que j'ai 4 c'était le
un coup je sais pas c'est encore celui
là le principal est aussi petit rock
bien évidemment pour éventuellement
prendre en d4 mais surtout pas cavalier
prend 4,1 pour les noirs enfin nous on
serait très content mais ça ce serait
une énorme gaffe typique
leeuwen qui réfléchit c'est lui qui tend
quand premier finalement dans cette
partie maxime a pris un peu plus son
temps pour développer les premiers coups
mais mais il a l'air d'être entré dans
la position qui souhaitait jouer il est
concentré en tout cas un maxime à 200%
heleven qui voit qu'ils essayent de
bomber le torse mais il me faudrait
mieux jouer des coups côté arménien
enfin côté américain désolé ouais il
sait pas il a plu la réf il va jouer le
petit rocha il serait bien que maxime et
laref instantané c'est pas dit qu'ils
les uns c'est pas dit qu'il est il fait
h3 il empêche rouge et
400 leeuwen un petit peu sous pression
il a peur de maxime le joueur américain
h3 il empêche fou g4 c'est bien joué et
là il est dans sa partie il est dans sa
partie maxime
leeuwen qui va devoir trouver une
solution pour son fou il peut peut-être
l'amener en bessette n'ayez pas toujours
bien placé il commence par tour 8
attention il peut y avoir des
carabistouilles angers 5 est-ce que des
prend 1,5 peut être une option fou prend
1,3 puis on prend un f6 c'est compliqué
hein il peut y avoir dans certaines
variantes des problèmes on rêve 7 à la
fin il doit y réfléchir maxima pions
prochain qu'ici vous prendre trois pions
prime si ça donne envie et c'est jouer
sa part faut prendre trois à l'idée
après puis on prend des cinq sur fou
prend 2,3 tu en prends un f6 foot pro f
2 temps point f213 officiera cavaliers
des quatre attaques la dame et tapez pts
7 c'est ce qu'a calculé maxime maxime
qui dès le premier coup de boutoir fou
prend pied en pro f 6 va être joué par
maxime et j'imagine fou h61 fff quatre
faux f4 il veut contrôler les cases
noires maxime qui va prendre en g7 ça
c'est quasiment acquis
à maxime qui calcule d'amd 5 au dam des
cinq est pas loin de gagner fou preuve
cette non plus haut c'est pas loin
hausse est à deux doigts l'ordinateur
continue à donner égal mais ce serait à
deux doigts de gagner oh c'est pas de
bol eu c'est pas de bol eu il envoie le
dam des cimes qu elle est bonne les vonn
qui est pas bien on sent qu'il est sous
pression les bons rend le marlou
américain qui est sous pression et la
seule variante pour maintenir les flots
donné par par la turbine est ses
cavaliers 5 à l épreuve 5 fu aussi ce
très difficile à voir est ce que c'est
dans le règne de lemon est-ce que c'est
dans le règne de l'even elle est
difficile celle là sinon c'est tout
réfuté ces avantages blanc a laissé un
moment clutch de la partie plus qu'une
50 pour les bon il est pas bien autant
maxime qui met la pression on le voit
physiquement là il a vraiment envie de
revenir dans ce tournoi de maîtres
l'impact et les bonnes qu'ils trouvent
exceptionnel les bonnes qui trouve le
coup c'est un grand les bons qu'on a en
face cavaliers prend 1,5 et fou aux 6
quel niveau de jeu les amis il a aura
extraordinaire le fou prend 3 x 4 avec
le cavalier ou cinq fois aussi ce qu'est
ce que c'est bien joué de la part du
joueur américain
rien n'est encore fait un an cette
partie maxime qui peut maintenir la
pression peut-être avec dams et 6 fou
prend cavaliers detroit essayer d'aller
chercher le le pion à 6 mais en tout cas
quelle série de coups joués par par les
bonnes trouver cavaliers 5 est fou aussi
c'était pas une mince affaire et
maintenant il faut que maxime aïe aïe
tenté de chercher le pion il envoie
cavaliers pro f cette hausse s'ajoute
tactique dan f6 d'un problème si c'était
aussi le seul coup pour pour les bonne
voie il a tous les coups du tennis à
l'aller bond exceptionnel si en train de
faire le joueur américain face à maxime
et maxime n'a pas encore dit son dernier
mot d'âme des uns il revient et il
protège le fou s'est passé ça c'est
sympa été pris 1 c'est pas c'est pas ça
qui l'a pris il a pris un rêve cette
maxime qui va devoir prendre réussisse
et je vois un petit coup de tours d un
pour protéger son pion non il fait
cavalier d2a mais il est fou prend des
2es et tout reprend et tout reprend 1,4
et ce qu'il a une idée là dessus je ne
crois pas ça semble ça semble compromis
maintenant pour jouer la gagne tours 8
les veines qui récupère pas le pion tout
de suite mais qui va pouvoir le prendre
au prochain maxime peut pas vraiment
joué à froid ce serait trop trop
affaiblissant c'est énorme ce casque a
joué les bons dans cette partie c'est
énorme
une défense majuscule vous prend des
deux dames prend des deux tours prend
1,4 il ya peut-être encore quelques
petits problèmes à régler au noir ya ce
pion à six qui peut être faible il ya
que deux options devant le roi ça peut
être un autre problème maxime continue
quand même à voir légère pression il est
mieux au temps
levon n'a pas très envie de jouer fou
prend des deux est rentré dans cette
finale c'est intéressant
psychologiquement il craint le joueur
français et du coup ils décident de
jouer ici je me demande si maxime va pas
jouer un petit tour aux deux provocateur
il fait cavalier f3 dont ils décident de
garder le cavalier du coup maxime le
cheval reste en jeu
attention les vins n'est pas très bien
autant valoir que maxime clutch
à prendre quatre à la maintenance est
certain maxime qui va reprendre ça va
reprendre et maxime va peut-être jouer
un coup deux dames ont des trois
j'imagine vous allez avoir débarqué non
il va jouer g3 d'abord il chasse le fou
il prend les cases noires et il va
forcer le fois repartir vers g5 et
peut-être maintenant maxime va rentrer
dans cette finale après cavaliers prend
puis on prend dont il commence par dame
détroit il met un coup de pression
encore un coup intermédiaire ça joue
très très bien là les amis c'est une
grande partie là qu'on voit adams et 4
probablement le coup mais une dame
français quatre pions prend ses 4 et
maxime qui va tenter cavaliers pranger 5
peut-être et tour à 4 tours b 4 jeux
sans maxime tenter quelque chose de
cette veine là alors il va peut-être
commencer par ouais enfin on voit qu'ils
s'approchent la main de du roi il fait
h4 en premier un coût qui m'étonne
personnellement mais ça doit être bien
joué depuis tout à l'heure les joueurs
jouent vraiment fort il veut envoyer le
foin et fils et jouer cavalier des deux
cavaliers france et 4 maxime et c'est ce
qu'il est en train de faire fouet six
cavaliers des deux c'est pas loin de
gagner un très très franchement on n'est
pas loin il veut tout re 2 qui arrive
lancé quatre des cinq rois f1 j'imagine
la tour qui part du coup angers 4 et
maxime qui va peut-être pouvoir envoyer
tour à 4 tours b 4 3g 2 maxime qui
montrent le roi des saints qui défend le
pion il n'est pas loin maxime de prendre
l'avantagé dans cette partie il est
vraiment pas loin il faut qu'il trouve
les coûts tour eux un salaire un poil
juste salaire un tout petit peu juste
alors didonne +105 mais très difficile
il faut trouver f4 ou proches qu'à 3h 3
c'est très très difficile f4 est un coup
très compliqué mais plus que 6 secondes
apparemment pour les bons à les maximes
y la f3 ton g6 h5 et g4 il a fait
l'expansion les vents qui est très mal
autant
non il a joué différemment maxime n'a
pas j'ai pas bien pu boire mais en tout
cas il a bloqué la tour en 1 h 3o il à
deux doigts il ya encore h5 j'ai cinq
ans maintenant c'est mieux pour les
noirs aux le manque de bol eu le manque
de bol eu ces terribles ojla pas la
baraka leeuwen il a la baraka les amis
et maintenant ça va être gagnant au noir
c'est terrible à ces terribles c'est
terrible parce que ça aurait pu gagner
ce qu'il a fait à ses la baraka pour les
bons c'est la baraka assez terrible ça
se joue pas à grand-chose un blitz
ça ne se joue pas à grand chose allez
faut mettre quelques barbelés espérer la
nulle
c'est pas encore terminée inception de
plus ce message ou encore le pion blank
qui arrive angers 6 quand même qui peut
créer quelques petites menaces le cas et
qui revient vers aux cinq la maxime a
fait un truc pas mal il a fait tout rage
cinq cavaliers ou 5 il a réussi à se
réorganiser à mêler vonn à food et cissé
ya pas qu'à y penser si ce terrible non
il a fait fou hausse est pas vu d' tour
f 5 maxime qui étreint en train de
[ __ ] le bordel
à les maximes il faut réussir un trou au
cavalier p 8 maxime qui revient dans la
game il va bouffer à 6o rien n'est fait
maxime qui a trouvé du contre-la au bout
des six ans le fou qui fait mal une
nouvelle fois la tour qui repasse
derrière il y avait 4 puis on prend tout
re 5 tours au 6e tour prend 6,6 et les
douches il ya peut-être les douches qui
partent mais surtour 5 le problème c'est
qu'il ya roi f7 il va faire tour à cinq
tours à
3o c'est peut-être très bien joué il ya
le punto qui part à l'époque y aller
petit leroy qui entre les verts une kia
deux doigts de perdre le roi qui va
rentrer en mai six c'est ça va gagner
allez maxime allais maxime avant ce
petit provocation ces six va le chercher
tour à tour à roye b 7 ça va gagner ton
projet 3 pourquoi il a fait ton projet 3
pourquoi il a fait tout reproche et 3 il
avait roi bessette qui gagne
instantanément
il avait froid bessette qui gagnait
s'est pas fait encore s'est pas fait
mais ça va gagner le roi est coupée
maxime qui a vu le gain serwa 6
maintenant tour à 8,3 bessette c'est
terminé les amis maxime qui valent
cherchait il à wangen il abandonne il
est grand maxime il est grand il est
grand les amis il allé se la chercher et
les bonnes qu'on annonce est champion du
monde ya encore 10 minutes quito ronde
face aux français
mais voilà les grands joueurs dans les
grands moments les amis c'est les grands
joueurs dans les grands moments c'est la
victoire maxime tout seul sur scène y
range les pièces regardez moi cet homme
y range les pièces le joueur le plus
respectueux du circuit vous l'avais en
face de vous mais il va quand même les
chercher les gagner le marlou à laymont
maxime plus que quatre plus que 4 c'est
tellement le boss les amis ça gagne au
ca fait plaisir
ol fait plaisir celle là
elle fait tellement plaisir à certains
géants les amis il revient
il revient les amis y revient dans le
tournoi maxime il ne fallait pas
l'enterrer
il a retrouvé les coûts
il ya retrouvé lékoumou maxime et là il
va faire peur à tout le monde magnus est
complètement lâché je sais pas ce qu'il
a fait mais on s'en fout on voit même
plus on voit même plus derrière où il
est il est dans les pièces derrière
ce maxime qui revient mais vraiment
comme un boulet de canon
il n'a pas eu la réussite dans le
tournoi mais il est quand même là c'est
quand même un monstre un c'est quand
même un monstre sera le roi bessette pas
jouer incroyable
ouais ça va envoyer là
là ça va envoyer il a plus qu'à un point
de la tête
il est plus qu'un la tête il est en
train de remonter très très fort
il a fait quoi dubaï
l'a fait quad ou boeuf double file a
fait nul contre artemiev des pommiers
achiri gaye 6 nuls maxime qui revient
maxime qui revient très fort un
maxime qui revient très très fort
maxime qui fait peur à tout le monde
maxime qui fait peur à tout le monde en
cette fin de tournoi il revient très
très très fort
non là il est bien en plus il éloigné de
carlson du coup il va peut-être jamais
le jouer
assez le moment décisif il reste quatre
parties
il reste quatre parties les amis
il lui reste à jouer il lui reste à
jouer tout à et du reste à jouer riga
ici il lui reste à jouer d'où bof allez
ce serait bien de doubler les blancs
comptent double officie il peut taper
double up en doublant les blancs ce
serait la belle op
les vannes reste grand favori perdre
avant on en reparlera dans une heure de
ça en tout cas maxime qui fait tomber
les bons
il est pas loin il est 5e le français
est en cinquième position
est vraiment plus très loin de là être
maintenant
magnus complètement enterré magnus ouais
il faudrait qu'ils gagnent toutes les
parties pour avoir une chance s'il fait
quatre sur quatre
cas maxime il est dedans
c'était vraiment une belle opéra de
battre de battre les bons façon c'est
obligatoire
c'était une victoire complètement
à doolow encore devant à douze ennemis
doivent très fort dans ce format a
vraiment va voir
à voir
jour 1
il n'y a pas de départage direct
malheureusement donc ça aide pas au
départage dans le scandale c'est le
départ d'aj de doug off qui avec deux
forfaits un superbe on départage c'est
terrible ça
d'habitude quand tu fais des forfaits
est un mauvais temps un mauvais un
mauvais départage mais mon maxime qui va
qui va gagner tout ça il y aura pas
besoin du départage
c'est elle
deux forfaits
le parent fait part d'une par forfait
n'est pas prouvé leur monde et
partageant les points à l'habitude quand
tu as atteint des portages pourraves
quoi
mais là ça va si gagne toutes les
parties les vannes il va pas faire il va
pas faire 4 sur 4 sur 4 en partant de là
le problème c'est que c'est dur de
gagner au noir
game peut-être contre double of
on peut espérer contre dubaï en doublant
en doublant les blancs
ce qui serait vraiment l'idéal en vrai
hein
la partie contre habib ça me fait un peu
mal ouais
y'a pas encore les appariements
katia qui est pas mal à louer dans le
tournoi femme il ya moins de partir dans
ton la femme
tu arrives
il ya ici c'est pas facile
l'autre façon y'a plus personne facile
irrigants ici c'est un excellent buteur
du beau fils boudouda
et magnus je veux toujours table et maxi
on n'aura plus à camille les tables 4
tout ça parce que carlson est bloquée ta
ble en quoi
ce scandale
ça parce que magnus monopolise la table
en fait c'est incroyable
voilà la table à cames 4 je crois qu'on
a que les trois premières
fêtes on a deux tables
on a deux tables trois tables hommes de
tape de deux tables trois tables mixte
de table femme
malade bleu on doit voir la table 1 2
3 5 et peut-être cuisne sûr
on à la 4
on va voir
lester qui joue tablant parce que
maintenant le sport en fait y'a plus
d'équité en vrai ce genre tu sponsorise
le tournoi et tu décides qui a gagné les
championnats du monde c'est ça la
logique du chat maintenant
bah dis donc
c'est beau ça
c'est beau ça la vision de l'équité
sportive magnifique le chat
c'est pas un tournoi privé la saint-jean
championnat du monde 1 pas tout à fait
la même chose en fait contrainte on a
privé c'est une chose
là c'est un championnat du monde c'est
pas tout à fait la même en fait
c'est pas le même le même délire
donc
donc donc on va voir
donc on va voir ce qui va se passer
c'est chaud et riga ici c'est chaud
ça va être très tendu
elle raison du partage entre iphone n'y
a pas de partages entre hommes et femmes
le tournant est mixte l'art il n'y a pas
de
les armer les femmes peuvent jouer dans
le même tournoi il ya une catégorie
exclusif pour les femmes et une
catégorie mixte
important de quand même
noté citant la question revient souvent
mais c'est pas vrai
7h30
mix non mais c'est par choix elle aurait
pu il ya plusieurs femmes qui auraient
pu participer aux
au mixte c'est par choix après d'aller
jouer dans la catégorie femmes mais à
la plusieurs femmes qui aurait été
éligible pour jouer
donc
12 points
drop marché aussi peut-être
c'est que les vosges ou un plot
on sait que l'on va jouer des plots
maintenant
une cocarde scène ça peut être pas mal
pour nous martinez pomy achi
un taux repartir en six minutes
en grèce gagne que les bons pères
et que tout bas fait nul il sera déjà
sur le lit de maxime
en quoi il est vraiment pas loin en vrai
hein
et en plus il va jouer du boeuf aux
blancs normalement au moment où il va
jouer du beau fils va jouer au blanc je
pense le prochain à part immense si
maxime fait pas n'importe quoi et du
boeuf non plus cmv l aube l'encontre du
boeuf qui est très bien
là c'est une bonne p pour nous que du
boeuf à 6 nuls en fait si maxime gagne
ce que je jouais aux blancs doux beauf
qui est un petit peu devant le battre le
sortir
jamais le choc à mai et se faire
remonter un point en quatre parties
c'est pas de choc a
juste eu fait 2vic 2 victoires 2 nuls
et 4 victoires pour maxime à côté ces
marins
et 6 rouges à qui va revenir et méfier
rouge à occire hodja il peut plus gagner
en fait
j'ai déjà le tournoi est terminé
en fait j'ai pas la table 4
sage et à table de carl scène
très important
ça c'est artemiev
c'est la table 5
et qui sait d'où boeuf c'est la table 3
est en fait celle que j'ai passé la
4c beau quand même d'avoir les tables 1
2 3 5
c'est magnifique
c'est logique après tout
mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez logique
apparaît pas super logique mais en fait
c'est très logique
c'est très logique à
ok
allez voir la partie allez les gars
nul possible gain bien défaite interdite
c'est simple
ça va partir et les cas leur île et 28
dans deux minutes
le prince du gange
contre maxime un duel au sommet
va falloir mettre le punto pour maxime
hutteau est important ici
prince du gange avec les blancs maxime
avec les pièces noires
le gange contre le rhône rires oui mais
ça va être dur de lutter
enfin savent ce fleuve sacré
ça va être dur ça va être dur cette game
gear in salah
il est complètement dans le tournoi à
vous m'entendez dire cette phrase depuis
longtemps mais ce qu'on joue la première
place la cif est nul ou même perdre il
peut encore jouer podium mais
il faut aller la chercher
il faut aller la chercher celle là
c'est à primordial
c'est primordial
allez bon maxime
il est vraiment dangereux et rigail si
j'ai déjà joué plusieurs fois sur che
scav en plus il est tellement bon
tactiquement
aller sa part on a trop joué par le
joueur indien maxime qui va renvoyer la
sicilienne fou b5 et chats qui commence
à être relou avec avec leur fougue et
sinko aller maxime qui va envoyer le
foot et ça a peut-être qu'il va changer
pour qui les 17 ans disent en prépa non
il va rentrer dans cette et audemars
hawks il avait bien joué un contre
martin graf 6 il avait une bonne
position il va nous refaire du g6 ou g7
on va voir les coups ils vont partir
rapidement je pense pas que maxime est
vraiment marqué un temps d'arrêt aussi
marqué sur le g6 de ça à faire des cas
puis on prend cavaliers prend il va
jouer avec fous j'ai sept cavaliers
apsys rock vous connaissez tous à parker
maintenant cavalier f6 rock rock et on
va voir ce qui a préparé le joueur
indien f3 est aussi une possibilité un
peut-être que sur sur roc direct les
cavaliers g4 nous voulons voir entrer
dans cette position je crois que le coût
est à 6 sébastien mazet on a joué des
dizaines en title tuesday il va jouer
sûrement à 6 pour aller chercher du b 5
c'est position un peu pénible à jouer
bien évidemment celle avantages des
espaces pour les blancs tout à l'heure
quand y jouer contre joueur ukrainien
jeu d'extase gré afin ce n'était pas si
grave et que c'était plutôt solide parce
que maxime était vraiment plus fort là
ils jouent contre un excellent blitzer
ils voient les tactiques plus vite que
son ombre avec avec les blancs et maxime
donc qui envoie à 4 à 6 pour préparer le
b52 ouvrir la position il peut avoir
l'idée de faire tours fc huit cavaliers
5 est sûr b3 b5 pour jouer par exemple
sur un clouage maintenant c'est aux
joueurs indiens de prendre la décision
et ce qui va jouer à 4 et ce qui suit à
jouer cavalier de2 il a joué dam des
deux dames des deux salles s car elle y
prend des quatre fous prend des 4 et b5
ce qui pourrait tenter maximin parce que
sur canal et prend des quatre dames
prend des cats on aurait du cavalier g4
qui attaqueraient la dame et le fou donc
ils forcent un petit peu fou prend et ça
lui donne b5 il peut aussi commencer par
b5 ça peut être une autre option est
sûre puis on prend en prendre à ce
moment là ont des 4 maxime qui pour le
moment garde la pression il joue tours
fc 8 et menaces cavale et prend des
quatre fous prend des capteurs france et
4 il doit espérer un coup comme b3 et
jouer b5 à ce moment là qui sera
d'autant plus fort puisqu'il aura
affaibli un petit peu ce ce quart à lyon
c'est en c3 qui sera moins stable
maintenant joueur indien a une nouvelle
fois de trouver les réponses un coût
éventuel serait cavalier 2 de rouleur là
ça va partir qui les prend des cas tv5
ça y'est maxime est sorti du bois il a
envoyé le betting causé égaliser maxime
qui a égalisé ici il a réussi à jouer le
coup libérateur b5 et il a cassé cet
étau qui prenait l'espace est maintenant
maxima une position tout à fait
convenable il va pouvoir travailler son
adversaire les chances sont à présent
équitable maxime qui a repris l'espace
ce qui peut peut-être un jour même
vouloir b4 et venir complètement fixé le
pion en a deux qui auraient du mal à
avancer à cause de la prise en passant
attention aussi un côté indien a pas se
prendre un cavalier prend 4,1 jour
quitte après la dame et le fourgon pour
le moment le fou est protégé mais ça
peut être aussi dans les bacs pour pour
maxime et son adversaire haroun qui
décide de jouer à 4 2 pouces et son pion
passé alors attention parce que ça peut
donner la casse et capot une tour et ça
peut commencer à faire très mal maxime
qui est dans sa partie maxime qui joue
vite maxime s'est réveillé et ça fait
mal à tout le monde tel un colosse
endormi il il a passé une journée et
demie mais là quand il met
l'accélérateur il fait très très peur
déjà 45 secondes avance et une position
qui commence à faire plaisir une casse
et 4 qui s'allume et s'y prend avec la
tour et le cavalier c'est la petite dame
qui va partir sur b sinko ça va
commencer à bloquer aux cavaliers pour
1,4 à une dame qui part en bessin qui
avait les v6 on a tous points
intermédiaires il n'y a pas de
fourchette et ça commence à taper maxime
est devant dans cette partie allez ça
fait mal tours b 1 et il va falloir
maintenant réussir à travailler alors il
est pas gagnant mais il est un petit peu
mieux il va pouvoir mettre peut-être la
tour ans et six jouets pour tous et 8
commencé à doubler et augmenter petit à
petit la pression il fait cavaler 17 il
veut échanger les fous de cases noires
et venir sa stalle éventuellement sur
ces 5 et venir et venir
fixer ce pion b3 bon objectivement on
s'emballe un petit peu on est plus
proches d'égalité que de guerre noire
mais c'est toujours ça de pris va jouer
avec six cavaliers ces trois dames b6 on
va échanger et on va essayer de jouer
sur le petit plus dans l'activité de
d'activités pour les noirs ils ce pion
b3 un petit peu faible mais aussi sur l'
avantage à la pendule 1 45 secondes
c'est pas à négliger la position est pas
simple à jouer pour pour les blancs et
il va falloir s'employer maintenant côté
haroun pour se maintenir à flot d'eau
qui joue cavalier c3 il se replace il
attaque la dame maxime qui va sûrement
partir sur un dame 5 je pense dame prend
et prendre 2 d je pense que c'est le
choix qui va faire ni parent b6 il
propose les changes des dames ils
l'imposent même les changes des dames
est effectué et maintenant il va jouer
tours fc 1 son adversaire et maxime va
tenter un tour à 3 à mon avis pour venir
se placer en face du pion b et le clou
et puisqu'il ya pas de bekkat il ya du
tour prend ces trois qui par wave ii y
montre le roy et maxime ici qu'il doit
chercher un coup de butoir j'ai peur
malheureusement qu'on n'ait pas mieux
qu'eux
que petite poussette sans plus il va
falloir trouver les coups ici
il va falloir trouver les coûts ça
paraît difficile de deux pouces et
ça paraît très difficile de pousser
cavaliers 17 il veut mettre le cas
l'alliance et 5 et un tout petit quelque
chose mais ça paraît très modeste il ya
peut-être tour ces deux cavaliers ces
cinq baies quatre cavaliers à 4 pour
jouer sur le clouage c'est à sémalens
coup de maxime
c'est assez malin
ça peut bien clic 1 ça peut bien cliquer
lecavalier en 17 qui est bien il hésite
maintenant rhône roi des deux cavaliers
ses seins qui doit avoir une défense le
cai prend b3 doit pas passer doit avoir
un il doit avoir un truc que je vois pas
personnellement mais il doit avoir un
truc
et voir un clouage un cavalier p5 ou un
truc comme ça est ce qu'il doit jouer f5
maxime pour aller taper de l'autre côté
de l'échiquier
peut-être cavaliers ces cinq rois ses
deux
paroisses et 2 ça pas l'air d'être le
coup de l'année ya pas un cavalier ac 4
qui traînent on allait peut-être 1 h 5 h
4g 5 allait prendre de l'espace de
l'autre côté il est peut-être un peu the
gang son adversaire ici cavaliers à 4
qui part et là il ya peut-être roi des
deux ans encore qui défend qui est
france étroite on pensait trois tours à
deux et fait roi des trois quilles et c5
retour le roi qui va revenir en c2 aller
maxime il faut aller pousser peut-être
de l'autre côté
je sais pas ce qu'il faut jouer les amis
la turbie très heureuse de faire h 5 h
5e jouer qui on prend plus on prend
c'était une autre idée assez logique on
va voir les coûts qui vont arriver en
rafale g35 croît aussi ce dessin qu il
part pour sa maxime il fait h5
maintenant il fixe allez peut-être un
aussi un corps aussi ceux des 5 des
quatre ça peut partir
ça peut partir et là y'a pas cavaler à
quatre heures autour
mais prend 1,4 tout reprend ses trois et
il n'ya pas y'a pas tour des 3 yaya
toure à 2 maxime qui est gagnant les
amis il prend les punto maintenant il va
faire tomber trois tours prend
tomber trois tours pour un f3 il va y
avoir tours 1-1 surtout rania peut-être
tour à 2 3 b un tour b 3 oya tour à deux
échecs tourcoing f1
tour à deux échecs tour préfère laisser
la victoire ça gagne 5 gagne ici mais
oui monsieur mais oui monsieur
il s'est réveillé maxime et il fait très
très mal à tout le monde il fait très
très mal à tout le tournoi les amis il
est de retour le joueur français et ça
gagne encore une fois et ça doit pas
être le cas de magnus carlsen qui suis
un petit peu au que oui on a acheté la
table numéro un mais on n'arrive pas à
lutter face au numéro un français il est
peut-être gagnant quand même magnus il
est peut-être gagnant
mais maxime remontant dans le tournoi il
fait vraiment mal il se passe quand les
autres partis guiry nepomniachi ça a
fait nul doute beauf qui a battu duda et
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir un m velde
ou bopha la prochaine aussi doux bofa
les unes blanc on arrête le stream 1 on
arrête tout il va aller voir maxime
l'encontre du boeuf et on va essayer
d'aller mettre le punto
maxime qui remonte très très fort
dans le tournoi et on va aller voir ce
que fait les bons
les bons qui est ici
contre eux
non non c'est pas cette partie là les
bons qui est ici contre martirossian
serait bien que martirossian fasse pas
n'importe quoi
ce serait bien que martirossian la
sienne celle là
je suis pas très confiant qu'avec
martirossian
attends martirossian et peut-être
gagnant vrai est ce que martirossian
irait pas nous enlever une épine du yep
qui fait de la merde à retirer
une fait peur martirossian
il fait peur le frérot
je vois qu'il fait de la merde ou pas
non je crois qu'il a gagné le cheval
mais ça a peut-être faire nul
mais les bons va plus avoir qu'un demi
point d'avancé sur maxime
il va pas la gagner celle-là ne va pas
la gagner ça lamarti il faut pas la
perdre par contre il faut pas se faire
arnaquer
allez le frérot martirossian va nous
faire une petite d'euros
ce serait pas mal il peut pas faire
mieux que nul ici
mon avis a pas mieux que nulle mais bon
c'est quand même une bonne au
pdf 6 free l'a pas pris le pion
pourquoi est-ce qui n'a pas pris du
rapace kg 5 en l'air il veut pas donner
j'ai cinq
sacs
sa clique côté arménien
sa clique côté arménien a laissé
arméniens contre américain mais ça c'est
drôle
ouais ça c'est drôle
ça c'est drôle les amis
ajkai qu'est en train de a
à a- qui est peut-être gagnant
maintenant ah oui là le plan bien les
vonn qui a fait une connerie il fallait
pas sortir le roi d'ici maintenant le
roi va être poussée ouais c'est un truc
assez dur à faire en vrai
en fait ils poussent le roi pour aller
le maté il connaît la technique prend il
doit avoir un coeur de battre les vols
en plus haïk connaissant la fierté
aux que oui bien joué moi avec bien joué
moi et c'est ça qu'on veut voir le
joueur à médian qui vient qui vient
faire mal à l'américain et oui c'était
sûr c'est sûr qu'ils avaient à coeur de
battre son ex compatriote ike et il l'a
fait à ça c'était sûr
toujours surmotivé les joueurs arméniens
dans ce genre de cas de figure est il
allé chercher le poteau oh que oui oh
que oui se regarde ça c'est sûr que
connaissons un peu les loustics il
devait y avoir une envie de gagner côté
côté eric décuplée et s'armer maxime en
tête les amis on va plus être très loin
de la première place
danil du boeuf premier levon aronian
deuxième et un maxime vachier lagrave
troisième au que oui oh que oui maxime
revient comme un boulet de canon
et y en a beaucoup qui parlait en début
de journée maxime était fini il n'avait
aucune chance de gagner il avait un
mauvais départage le pauvre au la
réponse du français qui fait mal à tout
le monde il est bien là maxime à léon
barbade ou bof si on est dans le lied
le punto contre double off
aller au blanc + 1
allée aux blancs les amis
allez au blanc les amis le départage
c'est pas grave si ben haddou baffie
sera seul en tête y aura pas besoin du
départage
est ce que vous voulez qu'on aille
regarder firoud déjà pour la prochaine
peut-être ouais c'est ça ce sont une
demande du chat
c'est dur du boeuf assez dur ennevelin
c'est très dur mvl mais il va avoir les
blancs c'est sûr si doux bouarfa les
blancs c'est le plus grand scandale
de l'histoire des échecs mondiaux en
fait
il peut pas avoir les blancs mais il
peut avoir une pub oh que oui
il est bien là maxime il est très très
bien allez les petits faut aller nous la
chercher celle là
manu ce qui est loin maxime qu'il évite
un peu pour le moment pas qui remonte
trop maimouni soit vraiment l'éviter
jusqu'au bout
je vais essayer d'avoir du plô qui
remonte un sma ne put vannes et
ambulants qui montrait serait
extraordinaire
n'est pas mal
ma les amis
dans ce tournoi extraordinaire pour le
moment
pas encore les appariements mais ils
vont bientôt arriver
on souffle un
tableau on va avoir magnus carlsen bien
évidemment table 2 ça va être les vont
encore alan table de cette double off ça
va être une belle du golfe
soixante prime time quelle femme tournoi
ça vaut bien une bonne pub avant les
combats finaux ah bah oui là c'est
magnifique 1 on arrive au bout du bout
avec peut-être un titre de champion du
monde
ça s'est resserré derrière à 12 points
et maxime elle est vraiment dans le bon
wagon 1
il est là où il devait être
sa rampe
minutes
il reste trois parties
il reste plus que trois parties 1
18h 18h30 19h
il faudrait qui gagne 1 maxime
contre double of las pour lui passer
devant
et après on verra ce qu'on nous donne
avec les blancs doux bof là c'est
vraiment le péno il vous me disiez il ya
quoi s'est il ya deux parties vous
disiez levon aronian impossible à
rattraper avec deux points d'avancé sur
maxime il aura fallu deux rondes il aura
fallu deux parties il aura fallu un
maximum bull en est derrière un haïku
ambulants et les bonnes qui s'écroule là
c'est dur dans la tête 1 pour les bons
y en ait eu ou abobo il est loin de toi
c'était une surprise d'un jour
le tournant rapide
vous avez dit qu'il ferait rien il a
neuf points il est 75e
dans les appareils manquons entérine
à voir
et puis c'est bien en plus que vrai
enfin double ça tombe au meilleur moment
faut vraiment le jeu aux blancs parce
que c'est important
je pense qu'il va le jouer une italienne
à partir
si l'un
mais bon on pouvait pas rêver mieux en
début de journée est d'avoir un maximum
la qui dépasse tout en plus il a battu
un adversaire direct la riaa ici c'est
un gars qui va être chiant pour tout le
monde
je pense que c'est vraiment plus fort
joueur du tournoi maxime ici
en 19ème bmw table de c'était annoncé
lvl du golfe table de l'even contre
heart et gnafron où ça fait mal de
prendre artemiev compter dans un mauvais
rush comme ça ça peut être difficile
pour les bonnes
certaines f pouvant plus clutch
magnus il vous contera mine basse est là
il est un peu de beau lui a mis
complètement perte de vitesse
cette annonce était forcément une
nouvelle double table de ces tests était
forcée
il ya tellement une meute derrière
vraiment arrêter magnus un
qui peut l'arrêter peut-être à 5 g mais
peut-être pas que fier rouge à erika ici
haci ali reza pouvait remonter
mais oui le hb je vais te dire je vais
les regarder où il en est au classement
et les carreaux
car oui les 99e actuellement
d'améliorer sondés partagent en
attendant en attendant maxime il en
train de se faire un départage ici il
aura pas forcément le siamois n'est pas
très bien bien mais
si artemiev pouvait gagner ça peut
peut-être nous arranger en fait
éminent karl scène est hors course il
sera jamais champion du monde c'est fini
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut pas le
jouer
peur magnus ce qui est chiant c'est de
le jouer enfin faut que vous compreniez
faut pas le jouer après il remontera pas
ce qui fait 14 14 et demi il sera jamais
champion du monde maxime la cie faire et
demi sur sur trois il sera pas champion
mais ce qui est relou c'est de le jouer
c'est papa
bah oui
si vous êtes assez intelligente pour ça
est assez débile pour pas comprendre ce
que ça veut dire je ne peux rien pour
vous c'est terrible
mal à retenir c'est pas un bon
apparemment pour les vents
à retenir c'est
a pareillement
ça va être chaud
si le premier un demi point de plus que
deuxième ya pas de finale non n'y a pas
de finale c'est un demi point de plus et
final que c'est à égalité de points
c'est maintenant un
nouveau buzz qui s'installe
il faut remettre le poteau 1
il va falloir
l'eau
le stress le stress les amis
tu es capable il capable de galère est
d'aller gagner à thuir est capable
d'être gagnée d'être aller gagner chez
les catalans pour le maintien tu es
capable
on fait quel mur là faut qu'on fasse un
mur moi je pense qu on fait un mur de
marloux
je propose de un mur de marloux je pense
que la cdm arles ou en fait qu'il nous
faut
à mon avis c'est clairement des marleau
aujourd'hui les traits marlou max maxime
et c'est le mur de marloux
qui peut nous sauver
un grand mur de pareloup bon ben ça va
tu es motol lier ça va être marrant du
mur de marloux un
chat tandem automne les murs de marloux
qui part à mon avis il ya que ce genre
de mesure qui peut qui peut tout décider
je pense que maxime
va envoyer
une italienne
dans des messages cephas bibi qui me
la femme qui arrive tout à l'heure
le mur de marloux qui part à laymont
maxime face et maintenant il est beau ce
mur de marloux il est magnifique ce mur
de marloux
le mur de marloux qui part bon ça fait
plaisir un mur clutch
un mur qui peut cloche le mur de marloux
aller maxime
j'aimerais tellement qu'ils gagnent vous
n'imaginez même pas qu'elle a quel
plaisir ça procure et de voir maxime
champion du monde d'échecs ce sera un
descriptible ce serait indescriptible de
voir
notre champion
remporté le tournoi sera un tel bonheur
à ce serait se serait géant
ce serait géant
et le mur qui est sorti
les magnifiques mur
le plus beau mur de marloux du monde
il ya une vraie pression je vais voir ce
que ça dit côtes américains est ce que
ça sue côtes américains
est-ce que ça sue
sassus du lourd un côtes américains très
clairement ça sue du très très lourd
du coup il monte le tournoi féminin côté
côtes américains issus du lourd
ca c du lourd américains et où ils ont
vu le retour de maxime et il sut
wrench en sueur
face au champion français
au dessus de tout maxime
ça va être extraordinaire
ça va être extraordinaire les amis cette
partie
qui vaut cher
qui vaut même très très cher
c'est le genre de partie qui change tout
il passerait il prendrait la tête du
tournoi maxime à deux rondes de la fin
c'est une partie tellement importante
maxime il a l'expérience de ces grands
moments maintenant du boeuf aussi un de
boeuf c'est vrai qu'il est il à laleu il
a le même profil que moi ça fait ça fait
peur toujours
jeune et qui se présente quand même
savoir je mets profile aussi ça se
présente largement ray sais pas si je me
présente pas plus que lui quand même il
se présente comme il se présente johan
je dois avouer qu'ils se présentent
quand même je fabrique qui se présente
se présente fortement
je dois oui
mais bon
maxime avant le nez
maxime passe avant le nez les amis
allez mon max ou
aller chercher cette victoire
c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite
elle va être elle va être important de
cette game
nul le laisse en vie quand même maxime
nul n'est pas éliminatoire 1 défaite et
éliminatoires mais nul laisse encore une
chance parce que on n'aurait qu'un demi
point de retard ont gagné deux dernières
on est on est dedans aussi un donc la
victoire n'est pas obligatoire
surtout que ça va ça va contrôler après
ça va qu'on après
il faut absolument qu'ils fassent le
punto lamont maxime
bien que ça y'a que le punto ici
et que ça devrait
en plus il aligné avec katia c'était un
signe du destin
c'est peut-être un signe du destin pour
notre maxime
et on va espérer on va pousser on va lui
donner toute notre énergie
il alerte les maxima
il al'air giga déterminer c'est un petit
peu parlé ce matin par par message je
lui ai dit j'ai dit vas-y tu vas tous
les bouffées frérot
il était quand même assez confiant
j'avais un peu peur du troll après avec
l'épisode qu'ovide mais il a eu un peu
de bol un contre galles fendent
du beau fils et qu'il est moins fort que
maximin mais bon sur une partie
tout peut arriver
partir
twitter sa part les deux hommes se
serrent la main maxime qui envoient eux
quatre ces cinq sicilienne de double of
qui envoie pas le 4-5 habituel et des
six il veut faire goûter à son propre
poison maxime maxime qui va jouer les
taux de marc auxi lui aussi on lui en a
joué deux auparavant avec les pièces
blanches et il décide lui aussi
d'envoyer il joue avec d'amener de huit
jours une variante un petit peu
différente maxime va peut-être jouer
autour d un des quatre et maîtres
maîtres du coup en place un autre un
autre type de position aussi ce maxime
qui réfléchit du beauf qui est un joueur
très
originale qui peut avoir décidé de
l'ouverture il en voit qui a valu au
sein qui semble le savoir ce qu'il fait
du beauf il est tout le temps dangereux
il a vraiment beaucoup d'idées dans les
ouvertures et maxime là qui semble un
tout petit peu dépassé cavaliers
préemption prend et détroit donc c'est
une position
avec une meilleure structure de pions
visuellement pour pour maxime mais le
problème c'est que le pion des trois
îles arriérés on n'arrive pas à le
pousser et donc malgré les railleries il
peut pas le pousser et malgré les pions
doublet maxime qui peut avoir du mal à
avancer dans cette position et parfois
il faudra même joué un f4 pour enlever
ce contrôle du centre au noir en tout
cas l'ouverture semble plutôt une
réussite pour pour le joueur russe qui
est
qui a fait le bon choix de partir du
vieux 4,5 pour aller dans la sicilienne
mais peu importe maxime qui envoie avec
à 3 tours ben il va vouloir jouer b4 et
prendre de l'espace aal.l dam tour des
huit peut-être un b 5 1 qui peut qui
peut partir mais c'est solide un ce pion
c5 et ce pion et ses pions eu 5 et c5
tiennent bien en respect le pion détroit
qui n'arrive pas à avancer
maxime qui joue g3 il va essayer de
jouer avec f4 il va vouloir faire sauter
les verrous et du boeuf qui joue b5
hausse à l'air d'être très bien jouer sa
part par dany dan hill qui cliquent les
coups un essai bien joué elle a levé 5
aïe aïe aïe maxime qui est un petit peu
derrière pour le moment dans cette
partie
ça s'est senti un au rythme de jeu que
dan il
avait les cookies qui lui venaient qui
on prend ces signes qu qui part il
reprend ses 5 du cheval
à la position 1 dany ici où il prend
même du fou j'avais pas très bien vu fou
prend ses cinq dames français 5 maxime
un peu dans le dur on va plutôt espérer
une nulle maintenant rien n'est pas bien
maxime ici
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe du beauf qui a sorti
la grosse prépa au bon moment et la drau
qui a accepté par maxime
maxime gestionnaire il a raison pas le
choix
il n'était pas bien
après pas et qui a fait mal aux joueurs
français
et maxime qui prend là nul il n'avait
pas le choix ils étaient ils n'étaient
pas bien là déjà
plus très éclairé en bon père de famille
maxime qui prend qui prend là nul
et d'aller voir ce qui se passe du côté
de l'even
7 nuls un petit peu dommage mais
c'est mieux ça que de perdre il n'était
pas bien on peut aller voir ce que fait
fi rouge a en fait
avec les blancs
il ya qu un demi point de retard un
maxime
et il n'avait pas la position ne pouvait
pas se permettre de la jouer en fait
pourquoi pas roja du
étonnamment n'a pas pu roja mais on va
garder là on va on va mettre la caméra
sur à rogner aronian ce thème important
en fait
quand même regarder aronian parce qu'
il faudrait pas qu'ils gagnent en fait
les bons
seydou ba fois qui a proposé nul
maxime lui les ils devaient ils devaient
accepter il n'avait pas vraiment le
choix en réalité
quoi ici draw a
ici on veut tous la victoire de l'évent
on veut tous sa victoire de levon fait
voir gelée rejeté un oeil au classement
maxime presque avec son mauvais
départage il doit 2 sur 2 ans maintenant
fait voir il en est où
reste rait ennemis
en fait nul ça va en vrai
nul ça va
juste
années s'écoulent
juste pas que les bons gagnent
c'est me faux
victoire artémias fait encore mieux en
fait
victoire témoins fait juste génial en
fait je pense
à voir
ça a l'air d'être bien pour artemiev
j'ai l'impression qu'ils craquent les
bonnes
impressions que ça craque côté les bons
amis des deux doubles c'est de se dire
qu'en fait la cif et un sur deux il
s'assure carrière quasiment les
départage
mais il gagnera pas les deux prochaines
double of
fear ou qu'ils gagnent cheyrou il
remonte fille rousse il fait figure où
il en est et où au classement
l enrichir où il est trop loin en fait
0 et remonte à
13,0 il est trop loin pour à gagner le
tournoi
il peut peut-être mais oui ça paraît
dans fear où il est trop loin
siro il est trop loin
mais cheyrou peut jouer double of non il
peut pas faire flotteur sur du waf
à voir ce que fait les vents
calais veut ne va pas gagner ce plus
important c'est que les jeunes gagnent
pas pour pas avoir deux mecs devant
au pire nul c'est pas grave non plus je
pense victoire hdmi a fait un peu mieux
mais nulle et coule aussi
dans les américains qui vont suer
donc maxime va voir qu'un joueur devant
ça veut dire que suivant ce qui se passe
même un ennemi peut l'amener au
départage
2.2.1 peut lui faire gagner le tournoi
il faudra gagner une partie au noir ça
va être dur
c'est ingagnable pour pour les bonnes
donc ça va le
à la victoire contre du bois forêt mis
tellement bien ça aurait mis vraiment
maxime seul dans le lit d'un butin quel
dommage
mais maxime il n'avait pas la position
pour pousser il était mal
qui valait pas pousser un truc où il est
moins bien dans une situation il est pas
obligé de le faire c'était ridicule
accepté nul était logique en fait c'est
plus la question c'est est ce que dubaï
aurait dû la jouer ou pas il avait la
bonne il avait une bonne position un
maître le fonds ancien et non les bonnes
les bonnes que le chat donné gagnant
il ya encore une heure et demie de sa va
vers 0 sur 3
la tour prend l'air froid et c'est
terminé ouais
terrible
dont il va être un demi point derrière
maxime et
ça va en être terminée de ses chances à
levon
je peux vous le dire tout de suite tonya
s il va falloir se le coltiner un
c'est pas un joueur facile
c'est gagner les bonnes qui s'écroule
c'est l'information de cette ronde
leeuwen s'écroule complètement dans ce
tournoi
il ne gagnera pas
hélas à gagner pour magnus et ça ou pas
attendez on va aller voir les peaux qui
a perdu contre sinndar off qui doit pas
aimer les ouzbeks
et pau qui a perdu une époque il sera
plus en course non plus
car la scène qui a gagné contre arvind
bassem attention faut pas que maxime le
jouan
ça peut être dangereux fauqué des gens
entre c'est pas le bon gars a joué
mvele artemis et nord artémias va
peut-être jouer du golf
en vrai
les martirossian qui va perdre contre
alexanian quoi ok
je vais regarder arte est du golfe ce
sens là nul ou pas sur un fond alors là
c'est quand même pas le voir le plus
apprécié en russie
surtout artemiev peut avoir un côté un
peu un peu jalouse oulad avait expliqué
un dans un live en fait comme du bois
habitat moscou les beaucoup d' aides
de l'état et de la fédération ce qui n'a
pas forcément été le cas de
artemiev comme il est pas moscovite donc
à mon avis
ça peut faire nul mais peut ne pas du
tout vouloir faire du lucien
artemiev c'est pas dire
qu'il faut voir qui maxime peut jouer là
fait nul
est ce que 12 of a déjà joué artemiev en
fait ça la question
non donc c'est vers ça est à retenir
faux blanc contre double up normalement
et mv
elle
merdy devrait prendre duda où ça c'est
un bel appariement
sea doo dah a gagné va prendre duda
ce soit plus de bonnes a pareillement
maintenant
à duda duda paris me joue encore
il manque une colonne et c'est pas grave
y'a déjà les résultats
ouais normal on maxime va jouer duda au
noir
artemiev va jouer d'où bof
je pense c'est difficile j'ai pas
classement sous les yeux de vos phares
team est déjà joué
va retenir qu'ils ont fait nul
il a déjà joué duda ou pas
aussi
bas face
mon en fait en vrai
et chou guérison fait quand ils ont fait
nul
valser tout à offrir ouais
non elles veulent ça doit être à retenir
f
est-ce que les couleurs correspondent
way
n'atteignait que c'est chiant
et d'où peuvent s'il va jouer soit
sinndar of soit fier où il va jouer
firoud sûrement
axe
routier remonte bien
les réserves de sur 2,6 baddou bof ouais
alireza sa dépense et apparemment il
peut aussi revenir
firo en fait quand il est dans une bonne
lancée il peut être encore plus
dangereux que maxime en vrai il marche
peut-être encore plus à la confiance
est là il est sur une lancée
ces fameux tournant si on tourne la
suisse c'est tellement plus marrant en
coupe ce cas être tellement de
[Musique]
départ
compte
des paquebots sinndar off ou que sindara
fasse une grosse game 1
mais ouais après il ya aussi cas de
figure où
n'en firent ou dubaï je pensais plutôt
bien puisqu'il va être sous pression et
fier où je pense qu'il s'en fout
complètement il joue à mon avis encore
mieux quand il ya de la pression comme
ça donc
reston tu commences en suisse si tu
prends le top 16 et tu fais un bracket
ça ce serait trop logique
en tout
à fuir ou lille veut jouer du golf parce
qu'il doit remonter
c'est sûr
il doit filer un point gratuit contre
icare way
placement savane à peu près ça
au classement et par jour
fait ça fait tout bof
14ème vail a émis f très élue miss
fait maxime même un ennemi ça peut
peut-être aller
les a pas man
ouais artemiev mvele
dubaï rouge à mes devoirs fille là
encore les blancs bien n'a pas besoin
d'avoir les blancs
carlson nepos ça va être marrant
et alexei and co duda
et pas besoin d'être blanc doux bluff
bon
et au départage maxime il est bien après
il est troisième pour le moment maxime
il est juste derrière artemiev au
départage mais il peut ça veut rien dire
il peut le rattraper au départage
jean avril un si bon départage en ayant
joué deux forfaits double off ça ça me
dépasse quand même
fofi roues un nul ou gain de toute façon
mais si firoud gagne en fait ils
rejouent le gars aussi du tournoi au
c'est bouillant en vrai
en fait victoire de fuir ou nous
mettrait très bien armés sur wii l'un
des partages dégueulasse
en fait si la victoire de fierro nuls de
maxime ça nous met très bien aussi
faudrait pas que les deux jouent pas ce
qu'ils pourraient tous les deux avoir
les blancs à la dernière
si elle veut aller firoud gagne dernière
ronde mvl firoud
clairement
très très clairement
les risques cheyrou force trop et je
pense que double of pop petit slip tas
de bois va tellement vouloir nul après
il ya risque du waf force trop
vous
bien je le vois pas ça rime
vous m'aviez dit qu'ils étaient très
forts sarine en blitz un nul et là on se
fond et demi vous m'aviez a annoncé un
crack absolue je ne vous ai pas cru et
j'ai eu raison
non mais n'est-ce pas du tout gagner dit
oui vraiment très très fort
comme quoi favori du tournoi quasiment
en tout cas ce match non j'ai pas mieux
que ce classement là tu as tu eu montrer
il ya douze ennemis
et vous pas la gagne
ça rit non ce point et demi un bon
ce soir
ennemi maxime maxime très doux bof 14
artemiev 13 ennemis m machin 13 ennemi
c'est sûr j'ai créé ce moment les yeux
c'est double 14 points artemiev 13me mvl
très et demi
après
si maxime fait nul et que firoud gagne
par exemple tu aura plein de gens à 14
et maxime peut gagner la dernière et
clutch
qui peut se passer beaucoup de choses
encore un
ce qui est sûr c'est karl ça ne sera pas
champion du monde
ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
pour le catch up buchholz pour les
adversaires du joueur c'est parti pas à
jouer pour quelques raisons que ce soit
by dédié retrait et quel que soit le
résultat il doit être considéré comme
nul contre lui-même mais en fait c'est
vachement avantage de 20 20 c'est non
seulement tu fais un forfait mais en
plus sa tête en départage quand tu finis
devant
c'est tellement avantage
terrible
pour ça qu'il a remonté partage
ah oui bah oui c'est non seulement tu
fais forfait en plus admet du départage
c'est n'importe quoi c'est vraiment le
beau lui un
ânon mais c'est
terrible
bon allez info que maxime
dur à dire s'il faut gagner ou faire un
nul ici c'est dur
un gag arrêté 99e tout à l'heure je sais
pas combien il va finir mais il est il
est pas bien hikaru
il est pas bien
comparer à maxime qui lui est très très
bien
et alireza qui remonte et on l'a pas
trop vu
sous marine aide
mais il est bien aussi
le français
et deux joueurs français qui sont qui
sont bien placés
d'où peuvent déjà installé
ses patients
le 3 on va y aura un jeu pâture sur qui
et tout les calmes
ah ça stresse dans le chat ça stresse
dans le chat à 13 partout
j'avais commencé le toit par 0 à part un
demi sur trois arrêts hélas pas un super
départage ça peut peut-être aidé maxime
ça s'ils font nulle et que maxime gagne
la dernière ça peut
[Musique]
ça peut clutch
ça serait ce un peu quand même je vous
cache pas
table numéro 3 maxime installé avec les
noirs
voir ce que ça donne en faudra voir
l'ouverture l'avantagent ses carottes
artemiev c'est pas le joueur le mieux
préparés du circuit
donc avec les noirs
maxime il devrait
pas être en trop grande difficulté entre
guillemets
ça c'est plutôt cool après artemiev
c'est un tellement un bon boxeur
les classements et le au blitz en blitz
actuellement numéro un mondial du coup
nakamura numéro deux carlos n
thema la taille des classements
ces terribles faits d'armes à camurac
arles c'est numéros 1 et 2 alors qu'ils
y sus aux championnats du monde
maxime il est prêt il est bouillant
maxime
il est chaud bouillant
hélas la partie contre artemiev elle est
d'une importance capitale pour les deux
hommes
j'irai ils ont tous les deux besoin de
gagner en réalité
en quelque sorte
les deux hommes ont besoin de l'emporter
artemiev c'est sûr qu'il va vouloir
jouer le gars il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
de doute à ce faire
il ya aucun doute à ce faire il va tout
donner
vladislav
lui là les blancs il aura les noirs à la
prochaine il sait qu'il a besoin de
gagner maxime avec les noirs il peut
jouer plus en sécurité
et placé un contre ravageur
ça va commencer dans une petite minute
une minute trente
maxime bien concentrés
bien installé sur sache zain
le requin est prêt à sortir à bondir de
l'aquarium
artemiev aussi est-ce que c'est maxime
qui va avoir les nerfs les plus solides
dans ses parties importantes il a plus
d'expérience car tpf de ces moments là
mais arte mais je sais que c'est un
joueur aussi très solide très bon
blitzer imperméable à la pression
normalement
mais qui sait qui c'est les amis
il ya tellement de choses qui peuvent se
passer dans la tête il faut essayer de
faire vraiment le vide la juste avant la
partie c'est de se vider la tête et de
n'avoir que l'échiquier
vraiment passé en ultra instinct
sierra sans lever toutes les pensées
parasites les penser au titre
les échecs passés
faut plus y penser à ça il faut tout
mettre tout mettre de côté tous sortir
de la tête et réussir vraiment à se
concentrer sur une partie d'échecs je
vois une partie jouée à un coût les deux
hommes qui s'apprécient qui souhaite
bonne chance et artemiev kirouac
cavalière 3 maxime était au courant il
va jouer t5 attention ces petites
positions artemiev qui peut être très
très pénibles haut au maximum qui sent
le cavalier 17 mar lucarelli 17 il veut
jouer pour ossun qui la déstabilise
artemiev il le sort de son système haut
que c'est bas l'un d'eux maxime que
c'est malin c'est un petit peu le coup
du berger à la bergère et oui et des
îles et joue il ajouté quatre maintenant
ils jouent ces quatre pardon et dépensé
4 il a sorti à ça ça doit être assise b5
ça doit aller ça pour au noir il ya une
partie ça doit être qu'à roanne artemiev
d'ailleurs est normalement a6b 5 c'est
cool ici à six dames français 4b 5b 7
j'espère que maxime regard de la chaîne
moi j'avais fait il fait quoi le frérot
au scandale
j'ai jamais ça jean michel cadrage
non mais c'est du foutage de gueule
non mais il nous a scié dans la bouche à
le gras j'ai jamais vu ça je n'ai
absolument jamais vu ça de ma vie
jean-michel cadrage qui nous enlever la
cam ça j'avais jamais vu encore ça je
n'avais encore jamais vu pour les amis
on va continuer à suivre la partie et
maxime qui a joué à six dans un deuxième
temps j'ai l'impression qu'ils
connaissaient pas tout à fait il ne suit
pas la chaîne
fawcett rock rock on va avoir des seins
et faux bessette qui va partir mais là
j'ai peur que ce soit mieux pour
artemiev je suis étonné que maxime est
pas et pas commencer par a6b 5 ça
donnait l'impression d'être la variante
mail et ça ça peut être mieux aux blancs
parce que sur bessin qui va ya voir qui
aura lieu au 5 aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
mauvais début de partie
[Musique]
va jouer quoi il va jouer il va jouer b5
quand même cave a lieu cinq ça fait peur
mais y aura peut-être comprend des cats
et jouer l'activité a laissé dans le
style de max b5 cavaliers 5 puis on
prend des quatre qui est prend 17 fou
prend 17 fou prend 1,8 dame prend à 8 je
vais juge jeter un oeil rapide pour voir
si à la cam nan nan ils nous ont viré la
cam
c'est un scandale
ça c'est du jamais vu les amis
il a joué puis on prend des quatre ans
il est pas bien maxime cavale et b6
wen dans la position
la position qu'ils avantageuse pour les
blancs le fou qui vient au g5 la tour en
c1 quel dommage
position est difficile on va voir ce que
ça donne aussi du côté du côté d'ali
reza
voilà j'ai plus ma canne ans j'ai pas
j'ai pas les réglages pour un bon vin on
va que suivre la partie de maxime pour
le moment on va juger jeter un oeil à
celle d'ali reza comme ceux ci
et alireza qui est quasiment gagnant
a dit ali reza qui est super bien au
noir ali reza qui pourrait aller
chercher le clutch
au lalalalalala ça se passe plutôt bien
là ça se passe plutôt bien pour nous
il faut so lu ment que maxime tienne il
faut pas que maxime laperne alireza il a
l'air d'être très bien d'où boivent qui
est en train de craquer
giroux qui a l'air bien
ferroukhi hélas la caméra
il est très très bien alireza on a les
deux parties en même temps c'est
difficile à suivre on peut rester un peu
sur la position d'alireza roues noires
qui semblent être très bien contre dan
îles du golfe
les grands joueurs dans les grands
moments et alireza c'est un très grand
joueur un il peut complètement revenir
sur la tête il faut absolument que
maxime tiennent au noir contre artemiev
et on va avoir un resserrement en tête
avec les deux joueurs français qui
seront égalité premier ex-aequo dans un
groupe très serré mais là ali reza il
est bien il a ce cavalier à il a une
qualité de plus en réalité un il à la
cale de plus
il a une belle position alireza alfie
qui vit à angers quatre étapes sur le
pur f3 c'est pas encore gagné 1 malgré
tout on va les voir ce qui se passe du
côté de 2 maxime maxime qui lui aussi a
les noirs ils en petite souffrance mais
il a de la vence autant aller c'est
peut-être pas si terrible pour maxime
non plus
les deux français qui sont bien ils
marchent main dans la main ils ont tous
les deux besoin d'un résultat un
mutuellement alireza besoin du résultat
de maxime et maxime a besoin du résultat
d'alireza leurs destins sont liés
ali reza qui a la position en tout cas
pour ne pas perdre déjà
joué il a joué à six le joueur russe et
je crois qu'il ya eu un b6 de la part d'
ali reza qui vient contre attaquer le
fou nous peuvent peut-être en train de
craquer ici face aux coups de boutoir de
l'autre français alireza l'espoir des
échecs mondiaux déjà numéro 2 mondial
les destins sont liés on est dans un
on est dans un dénouement de type shônen
les amis la force de l'amitié qui peut
l'emporter et pourquoi pas un match de
départage entre les deux français à la
fin tout cas maxime a réussi à se
remettre il a de la vence autant lui
aussi les français qui sont en train de
faire un taf incroyable dans cette fin
de tournoi ces deux messieurs les amis
du boeuf qui est dans le dur on voit en
bas à droite la position de maxime qui
va pouvoir faire cavalier seul des cinq
pouces et 6 et se remet remplace
ladislav artemiev a plu à plus le réel
avantage qu'il avait il y à quelques
coups et maxime qui trouve les coups il
envoie le cavaliere des cinq la force de
l'amitié qui peut qui peut clutch hommes
s'entraînent de temps en temps ensemble
ils sont forts ils sont très forts
pas retourner voir la position du golfe
le suspense est insoutenable
ali reza qui protège son pion c'est une
vrai call de plus pour pour pour ali
reza ça a l'air de bien de bien se
passer
il faut qu'ils concluent alireza il faut
pas laisser s'échapper c'est la cale net
de plus doux peuvent dans le dur c'est
un des meilleurs joueurs du monde en
blitz ali reza i là il a eu des périodes
où ils bits c'est beaucoup surtout
chaise comme il est au dessus d'un nid
ko à son niveau max va falloir qu'il le
montre ces trois il va rendre le il va
rendre encore un pion cavaliers français
3 qui est joué cavalier prend fou prend
au moins il s'est débarrassé du problème
de cavaliers mais la tour qui rentrent
du pauvre qui cherchent du contre jeu et
peut-être qu'ici il va falloir trouver
les coûts et ce qu'il faut passer la
tour derrière c'est possible ali reza
qui qui hésite
ali reza qui hésitent la décision est
difficile
il faut jouer le bon coup ici
allez on va les voir aussi ce qui se
passe du côté de maxime c'est
insoutenable cavalière 4 c'est chaud des
deux côtés moi j'en peux plus les amis
ali reza qui hésitent tour cédé 8 ça
semble être le meilleur coup double sous
pression
à laymont alireza il faut aller la
chercher ça là
il peut y aller au tour précèdent qui va
jouer va aller tourner un échec tempo
c'est bien il faut pas tremblé et toura
email à tour derrière il a encore le
temps il a encore le tiempo ali rezaï
bloc le pion roigé de il veut monter le
roi
ali reza qui joue ses seins qui veut
protéger son pion il va tenter de faire
fou des quatre maintenant pour pour
aller échanger les fous est allé
cueillir ce pion à qui semble impossible
à pousser
daniel dubois qui est en train de
manquer du temps il faut être fort dans
la tête il faut être fort dans la tête
il sait tout rade c'est bien joué ali
reza qui continue à jouer vite d'où
peuvent qui commence à être mal autant
on l'a vu un petit peu je vais faire un
mouvement de tête pour aller voir
combien lui restait deux secondes ça
trahit une nervosité lâché le joueur
réussit c'est qu'il est mal il n'a pas
les coûts et alireza qui a l'air
tranquille il a l'air serein il a l'air
facile le joueur français du prof qui
trouve rien il sait pas quoi j'ai eu et
sat encaissa tank et ça tangue et puis
on prend tempo il remet pas bien le pion
au centre de la case mais c'est pas
grave la tour qui y en a 3 sur échec le
roi qui monte attention alireza il a
peut-être un g5 échec au ils agissent
incroyable 5 3 5 il n'a pas trouvé il a
joué des trois mais ça a quand même
l'air d'être un bon coup le détroit qui
par la tour qui va revenir en dix-sept
le pion des deux fous prend f7 roi je
suis tout prend 8 d1 dames ça devrait
gagner si ça se passe comme ça attention
ils doivent qui tente un tour f7 il fait
la dame attention j'ai un petit peu peur
mais il a dû calculer tous les échecs
alireza ouais il prend des cinq essais
gagner et c'est gagné pour ali reza
extraordinaire ali reza qui s'impose
contre sdu bois fait maxime qui va
chercher la drau et maxime qui va
chercher à drouot tout le monde va être
à 14 points les amis ça va être un
resserrement en tête du tournoi
les deux joueurs français qui ont fait
le taff maxime qui sauve la nulle au
noir contre contre artemiev c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire il est un petit peu
moins bien et alireza qui est allé se la
chercher contre dan îles du golfe et ça
va être une fin de tournoi incroyable
les amis il va y avoir tout le monde a
à
4 à
4 points on va aller voir ce qui se
passe sur les autres sur les autres
échiquiers c'est important car la scène
qui banner peau
qui remonte à 13 points et demi mais
mais ça sera pas assez pour lui qu'est
ce qui se passe sur les autres grosses
parties c'est difficile à dire parce que
là plus rien n'est mis dans l'ordre
alexei enhco duda ça c'est une partie
importante aurait qu'alexei nkoa
face le taf il n'est pas bien de joueurs
russes c'est terrible et les pas bien
joué russe
il est pas bien du tout il va perdre
contre contre duda
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe alex est une co qui
peut pas faire le taf
un iphone qui va être à 14m fait la 14e
beaucoup de joueurs à 14
mais ça va être obligé de gagner il va
falloir regarder les départage aussi
parce que les joueurs français ont pas
un super départage
belle fille route pour le titre alors
non celui qui
celui qui gagnera et arrivera à 15 ne
sera pas champion du monde parce qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup beaucoup de monde
les amis
il va y avoir énormément de monde à 14
et c'est même pas sûr que quand on gagne
on aille au départage
pour maxime ali reza parce qu'ils ont un
très mauvais départage ça se peut qu'ils
fassent pas 1,2 mais qui finissent 3
c'est loin d'être dit je vais aller re
jeter un oeil
à peut-être qui peut sauver nul quand
même à l'excès ienco on ça freine aux
affaires
elle est nulle celle là le fou en un an
le roi oui non elle est nulle le fou ici
après quand sa part de l'autre côté tu
passes le four en a cinq aileron f2
cedro
recife nul il nous il nous sort une
belle épine du pied à l'excès enhco
non il va la perdre
il va pas nous sortir des pignes du pied
terrible
il va pas nous sortir des pin du pierre
attendent je regarde un peu le
classement pour me faire un avis va y
avoir double of artemiev mvl les bonnes
duda a aimé en fait même si les français
gagnent c'est même pas sûr que ça
suffise
parce qu'il va y avoir trop de monde à
14 et aqueux un départage à 2 donc si
tout le monde gagne on sera pas en
départageant fait
mais bon
en gros
s'il ya une chance
mais firoud ça va être dur
alix enhco qui nous enlève pas des pin
du pied quoi
faut vraiment que ce soit m vue elle qui
gagne en fait en vrai
pas ce qui peut être devant duda au
départage éventuellement
mvele
rip sassi gagne c'est pas sûr qu'ils
gagneraient qu'il arrive au départage
c'est n'importe quoi giroud devant une
verrue départage
il était derrière à l'instant et piatti
passe devant ça va être chaud on va on
va pas savoir comme d'habitude à la fin
ça joue sur un coup de dés sur le
résultat d'un mec table 75 c'est
vraiment terrible
vrai que les bons gagne pas mais je
crois qu'il est gagnant
il a battu sinndar of
mind
très et demi est possible
et partage c'est la somme des scores de
tes adversaires en gros c'est un peu
spécial c'est pour ça que les joueurs
sont si énervé qui en est que d'eux
qu'ils fassent des partages à la fin
parce que c'est
pas super logique en fait
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est les règles
on les connaissait d'avancé vraiment eu
jettent une pièce tu vois ce qui se
passe
maxime inquiet je sais pas en fait on
n'a pas les classements
ils 26 ans
s'il va jouer qui en fait maxime duda
sûrement
maximo blanc en fait pour c'est mieux
qu'ils jouent pas l'un contre l'autre
maxime est firoud en vrai
parce que si je voulais haulotte j'ai
peur que s'il y en a un qui bat l'autre
ça suffise page et en ce sens il faut
qu'on en ait deux faut qu'ils gagnent
tous les deux je pense
classement sur trois on voyait mais bon
le classement de chasse bombe il est pas
juste donc vous regardez défaut
classement en fait
seul classement qui vaut cette chute
résulte
s'ils jouent à égalité après s'ils
jouent entre eux qui a une nulle bon on
va voir
avoir un évent mvl firoud ça va être
bouillant cette dernière ronde
car la prochaine grande 19 heures
je serais assez le truc officiel du
tournoi
chasseral
qu'officiel du tournoi
grâce et un diplôme et carlson s'est
finie en fait car ça ne peut pas gagner
si un jeu
et qui peut pas gagner c'est karl scène
ce qui serait terrible pour nous c'est
qu'il joue conte fil rouge à ce que si
ali reza gagner que maxime gagne dans ce
cas là il ya beaucoup de cas
on n'a aucun des deux qui gagne quoi
si maxime gagne nancy font 3e 4e non
on verra les gars ça va jouer maintenant
tout cas j'espère que vous passez une
journée incroyable en ma compagnie
dernier stream de l'année
sa clique
sa clique de ouf ça me permet de faire
une petite pub pour le stage à lisbonne
la petite pu bien placé
la petite pub très bien placé pour le
stage à lisbonne d'air si je vous ai pas
répondu vérifier comme j'ai répondu à
tous les gens qui ont envoyé le
formulaire
n'hésitez pas à répondre
n'hésitez pas à checker votre spam parce
que vous avez forcément reçu le mail
certes il est dans votre spam je me
permets de vous mettre au beau jeu vous
spam le lien si vous les désinformations
le stage à lisbonne du 13 au 20 août
vous avez les infos vous pouvez écrire
dans le petit formulaire sur la page
internet qui est dans le tchat n'hésitez
pas
c'est fini il reste une partie
c'est la last ça va être là la fin ça
peut être la dernière a forcément des
partages donc de toute façon ça va pas
finir tout de suite le seul truc c'est
que c'est la dernière où on est sûr de
suivre mvele et effi roues
pub aussi
je vais vous le dire le classement
oralement parce que leur classement il
est trop claqué au sol
leur classement est trop claqué au sol
non mais le lac amour est le travelling
de la came pour nous enlever mvl c'était
assez terrible
toujours pas les appariements
il faut victoire mvélé firoud
il faut victoire nva les firoud et
réfléchir
en faut qu'il y en a un des deux qui
gagnent de toute façon
ça va être tellement chaud
j'ai hâte de voir les appariements pour
savoir à quelle
quelle sauce on va être mangé ils
sortent pas assez apparemment ils ne
sortent pas
vail duda car le cndd ou bof les vannes
0 ce serait l'idéal
n'arrive pas à voir le
à voir
se lance en dix minutes 1
ça y est
mvl karl scène
fallait surtout pas tact à saint denis
pour mv années vont fuir ou aronian
à l'éviter de takhar le seul à ce moment
là mais bon
et les départage fait fallait car le
sense face tags par un autre joueur
artemiev duda
boeuf guiry
départage
à les deux tiers des partages c'est à
six roues mvele
assez chaud en fait
chopin on a les pires départs talent
mais maxime il est pas loin au départage
de duda
mais vous carlson qui est derrière mais
si ça joue à deux points de départage de
gars que tu as joué dans le tournoi
peuvent guérir mais bon guiry
normalement il va pas vendre la game
or les blancs
et qu'on la nie plan du comté
il a eu
donc je vous appartient la première elle
compte pas il a eu 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 ha mais il y en a annulé la
partie contre naka
pourquoi ils ont annulé la partie contre
maca
c'est ils y ont annulé la partie compte
n'a qu'à avec les blancs parce qu'il a
fait forfait
du coup il y aura nul et 1 blanc comme
ça troll mais le vol mais c'est fou
du coup il a 11 blanc 9 noir quoi
parce qu'ils n'ont pas compté
alors il avoue mentalement de polluer il
double les blancs à la dernière
comme ça c'est toujours comme ça ne se
fait pas toujours annuler tu gagnes pas
toujours sûr forfait parce que le mec
est un cas de force majeure quand même
faut quand même vachement debout lui
pour gagner forfait sur quatre force
majeure
sur comme saaba j'aimerais bien un
j'aimerais bien qu'il soit toujours
comme ça je te rassure 1
- sud le départage tu laisses les blancs
quand même
bon c'est comme ça mais bon peut-être
qui doit jouer contre guy et guy rey a
eu beaucoup de blancs aussi un
c'est comme ça
c'est pas dit qu'il va guérir mais il ya
eu beaucoup de blanc
même pas
non mais guérit fra 11 noir dit blanc
c'est terrible en fait
système suisse tu vas t'enfoncer des
formules mathématiques un
héritier mâle compte et ça lui en fait
une 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 ça va lui
faire honte aux noirs gris
mais ces systèmes fils ans un truc
mathématiques en fait c'est pas s'est
pas fait à la main
et on se noie rend plus du coup pourquoi
est ce que le système suisse a pas
renverser
cette fois vers 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ans
maxime blanc 11 blandine noir
heureusement
en fait c'est de gagner
en fait sans doute artemiev azrou
firoud fait en fait si firoud balle est
bonne en vrai
et que jude artémias fonderont on est
sûrs d'aller au départage avec fear ou
alors que syfy rouppert contre les bons
même si en fait la partie du giro est
quasi plus importante que la partie de
maxime en vrai
ça va suffire houpert c'est quasiment
mort en fait même si maxime gagne il
suffit qu'il y ait une victoire dans
artemiev duda ou dans du boeuf grillé
c'est mort
à partie de fuir ou est
aussi importante voire même plus
importante que celle de maxime
on va quand même suivre maximus conduit
depuis tout à l'heure et puis joue
contre carleton donc c'est un beau en
beau duel et puis peuvent nous enlever
les calmes aussi
maxime qui a enlevé le masque il en
avait marre
il en avait art
on est sûr qu'il fera pas un travelling
on est sûr qu'il y aura pas travelling
enfin petit tweet
ça va partir
en deux minutes
ce que carlson va laisser la wii non tu
rigoles
il va tout donner pour gagner
il va tout gagner tout donner pour
gagner le saumon
mais bon il joue plus pour rien je le
sens un peu fatigué maxime il joue plus
pour rien magnus
af
c 2e calmes sur maxime
ça ali reza d'accord on a les deux
calmes on va suivre les deux parties en
parallèle
des magnus ne donnera pas le punto ça
c'est sûr pas de cadeau il peut plus
être champion du monde il n'y aura plus
qu'un titre sur trois ce soir magnus
mais il va tenter quand même d'arracher
un podium pour ajouter une médaille à
son palmarès
allez il faut aller celle là
il faut aussi et surtout que tu alireza
gagne contre les vont déjà qu'on est les
deux français qui gagne et après on
verra
pourrait bien avoir un français au
départage
aller maxime faut faire le taf aller le
marlou
il faut aller la chercher celle là avec
les tripes ça va commencer c'est leur
maxime qui serre la main de magnus et
qui envoient eux quattro magnus qui
réfléchit l'envoi au sein qui va rejouer
une de ces espagnols mais ça va pas être
la même limonade que contre yann les
pommiers achi maxime les antilles
marchal il connaît c'est un des joueurs
les plus dangereux sur le circuit avec
les blancs on va voir si magnus réussi à
s'en sortir aussi bien qu'il ne l'a fait
dans le match de championnat du monde
est ce que maxime va relever le gant
dont ils jouent à 4 ans tim marshall à
labaki l'école pakistanaise des échecs
les amis foulée cette maxime qui connaît
forcément il envoie le détroit il
protège son pion des quatre ils
préparent le développement du fou magnus
qui envoient des six cavaliers qui vient
en d2 maxime c'est ce qui fait pour le
moment magnus et un naître de cette
position mais face au numéro 2 français
à notre leader à tous les amis à notre
ministre il va avoir du mal la tour qui
part en 1/8 à hisser que maxime ne peut
pas faire cavalier g5 qui a valu à vii
pas de chantage la nulle mais qui a
validé fin qui va partir qui a valu aux
trois lecavalier qui va se replacer il
joue à six pour éviter les foules les
fous g5 maxime qui va mettre le quart à
lyon 1-3 il avait déjà fait passer un
sale moment à mine basse m dans le
tournoi maxime qui joue c'est 3 il
consolide son centre cavaliers fouet
fuite pardon pour pour magnus qui
replace ces pièces maxime qui mêle
carayon eux trois ils les jouent bien
ses positions notre maxime magnus qui va
mettre le cavalier e set pour venir
contrer l'avancée du cavalier 3 maxime
qui a toujours pas des quatre pour le
moment dans son règne a depuis eu quatre
en l'air il faut trouver comment avancer
et ce qui va prendre une fois en bessin
qu est ce qui va maintenir la tension ce
qui va envoyer un cavalier en h4 temps
pour le moment il joue un petit h 3
tranquille magnus qui envoie le cavalier
angers 6 attention à magnus qui est en
train de se placer il est dur à prendre
dans ses positions la joue en norvégien
maxime qui va peut-être devoir renvoyer
le cavaliere en f5 alors qu'on nous
annonce une drôle dans la partie de
doo-wop ça ce serait vraiment la belle
opération ça ce serait une très bonne
loi est double viry nul ouah ça c'est
une très excellente nouvelle ça enlève
un joueur de l'équation ça fait du bien
allez il faut aller la chercher
maintenant pour maxime celle là si la
gagne il aura des chances d'être en
départage faut aussi qu ali reza face du
boulot à côté cavs alliage de joué par
maxime on va jeter un oeil un furtif à
la partie d'alireza aussi parce que les
français sont tous les deux au coude à
coude au ali reza qui a sept grandes
positions théoriques au blanc il est
bien ali reza allez on peut espérer un
une finale franco française ce serait
extraordinaire mais on peut on peut
l'espérer à les raisins à la position
pour la jouer
dessine co qui a valu à g4 peut-être qui
part pour pour maxime
il prend des cinq
reprises et il va envoyer la dame en f3
maxime qui commencent à mettre une
pression sur vous allez voir les pièces
bouger sur l'échiquier commencent à
remettre la pression sur des 5 / f cette
cavale et h 4 de la part de magnus qui
contre attaque sur g2 ou ça fait
peut-être mal ce coup dame g4 qui avait
pris 3 et france 3 et ça va pouvoir
prendre angers de maxime dans le dur et
magnus qu'est en train de faire le taf
ici
maxime qui s'est trompé maxime qui s'est
trompé les amis
il est pas bien il est pas bien le
numéro 2 français
ce qui va jouer dame g4 peut-être qu'il
prend 3 33 les cg de en l'air et
attaquer magnus et concentré maxime
aussi
falloir trouver un bon coup ici maxime
qui joue dame
e4 qui est prend 1,3 d'un premier set où
j'ai peur les amis j'ai peur parce que
la position
semble très difficile maintenant pour le
joueur français magnus qui a gagné un
pion le pion g2 le pion devant le rock
maxime qui envoie la tour e 4 au niveau
du temps c'est magnus qui est devant
aussi un l'ogre l'ogre norvégien qui est
en train de faire mal tomber 8 dan des 5
peut être plus ou moins obligé échanger
les dames et m émettre une
et mettre une pression autour g4 magnus
qui a pris le pion le pion
d3s qui menacent d'amd un nom ses
couverts il menace rien pour le moment
cavaliers f3 s'est couvert aussi
il faut que maxime trouve un coup de
marloux ici tour g4 au très bien joué
tout rejet quattro tonge et quattro
menace surprend g2 et couvre et couvre
la case f3 et surtout rabé 8 il veut
peut-être un dam des cinq ou même
d'armes français 7 pour menacer en af 7
ouais c'est une partie à trois résultats
au que c'est bien vu que c'est bien vu
alors que fillon déjà et bien aussi de
son côté assez tendue c'est tendu on va
jeter un oeil furtif juste sur
l'échiquier d'alireza ou alireza un
immense avantage maintenant contre les
bonnes ali reza est pas loin
ali reza est pas loin d'y être allez la
france nos deux joueurs qui donne tout
dans cette dernière ligne droite dans ce
sprint
et la magnus qui commence à tanguer et
ce qui va arriver en dessous de la
minute on n'a pas le décompte seconde
par seconde je pense qu'ils se
retrouvent mal autant la halle magnus
ils se retrouvent mal autant ils
hésitent ils hésitent les secondes
s'égrènent il sait que maxime est très
dangereux dans les positions tactiques
comme ça là elle est concentré à 200%
notre français il est bien dans sa
partie la nvelle
fort comme jamais il est grand
dam prend h3 joué par magnus carlsen est
alors là il ya un coude ordi mais alors
qui fait mal c'est dante sinko pour
toucher 3 mais c'est quasiment
introuvables malheureusement maxime qui
a joué à un autre coup
il a joué tour g3 direct
la dame
qui est reparti je crois au f5 et
l'ordinateur déteste la position que
maxime et dames des cinqs était
introuvable l'idée c'était que ça tapait
sur et vii et c'était difficile de
défendre le pion correctement mais le
retour de la dame en
en f 5 fait mal parce que enfin deux
variantes il peut y avoir une tour ont
aussi semé bon maxime qui va prendre en
g2 ya pas encore tour aussi si adam
prend 1,8 et là et peut-être cavaliers
fin cavale et g3 pour colmater maxime
petit mais le cavalier angers chaos ils
menacent cavaliers pros h6 le marlou
magnus qui hésite il veut faire ou h7
our watch 8 il a plus beaucoup de temps
magnus aller maxime allais maxime où il
sait bien il tant qu' temps qui tanguent
leroy qui part en âge suite maxime qui
va repartir à qui va prendre en paix
cinq ans premier prise b5 ça s'est
échangé est-ce qu'il va remettre le
cavaillon et 3 il a du mal à à
développer sont fous
du ski mais la dame en h5 le cavalier de
maxime qui va repartir en d5 la position
est quand même tu va repartir en f1 plus
tôt la position est quand même mieux au
noir c'est plus facile à jouer c'est
quoi le matos mais il ya quand même
trois pions à ya beaucoup de pions il ya
quoi c'est quoi le matériel en fait il
ya deux pièces contre tours
et deux pions
j'arrive plus à compter les pièges
arrive plus rien a compté c'est
irrationnel il va faire quoi et faire
qui a valu aux deux cavaliers des cats
maxime rentrer dans cette finale il ya
quarante secondes contre 19 magnus veut
pas de la finale qui a valu aux deux
d'un match 5
maxime qui va peut-être repartir en d4
maxime est dans un mode swing mais
magnus aussi s'il veut espérer une place
sur le podium il doit gagner s'il fait
nul il ne sera même pas sur le podium de
la compétition il prend g3 maxime qui
est zidane prend g3 il pourrait y avoir
du tour des six tours 6
le joueur norvégien qui ramène une tour
sur la troisième ça fait très peur
maxime qui joue d'un f2 il contre
attaque en effe cette fois c'est
insoutenable f5 pour éviter la menace
maxime qui va mettre le fou en c2 il va
contre attaquer la tour qui va devoir
partir elle repart en d6 maxime qui
mêleront ans g2 ils commencent à avoir
du tout rassurant dans son règne autour
des huit tours h1 il attaque la dame il
se met en face du roi dame g6 leur tour
maxime qui joue tempo je vois plus tous
les coups mais ces bouillons
c'est bouillantissime ça semble
difficile avancés avec les blancs c'est
terrible c'est terrible les amis
ça semble plus facile à jouer au noir
assez complexe mais bon le foot tient la
casse des deux pour le mans mans fc 5
c'est bien joué il veut faire c'est 4 il
veut complètement l'enfermer maxime
emprisonné l'a dans le cul et dans les
pionts noir donne tout pour le mans
tours f1 il défend encore ils encaissent
le pion c4 maxime qui récupère un pion
est allé il va falloir réussir à mettre
la marche avant il va mettre la tour ans
et 5 fu b3 dans là il ya des coûts qui
vont pas on n'a pas les bons coups les
amis on va regarder sur la cam il a mis
la dame henri vii c'était aux blancs de
jouer le x e 5 c'est peut-être gagnant
c'est peut-être gagnant il ya eu dans le
g 7 matches qui arrivent trop h-13 h à
ces gagnants maxime qui gagne il est aux
portes oui oui petit ou un petit oui
petit il est allé la chercher au bout
iba champion du monde en titre dans la
partie décisive c'est incroyable il est
grand je sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait sur
les autres échiquiers des maxima gagner
les amis c'est extraordinaire on va voir
les autres résultats ils l'emportent au
bout du bout maxime qui va peut-être
chercher un titre de champion du monde
ici c'est incroyable les amis ce qu'on
est en train de vivre il est peut-être
champion du monde à l'heure actuelle au
moment où je vous parle j'en sais rien
j'en sais rien tout bofa fait nul je
sais pas ce qu'a fait alireza j'en sais
rien les amis et maxime et peut-être
champion du monde d'échecs on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas il est peut-être
qu'il n'est peut-être pas ali reza qui a
gagné c'est peut-être une finale nvlle
fillon rouge à les amis qui nous attend
c'est peut-être une finale
franco-française
il a été grand maxi ni bâle champion du
monde dans la partie la plus
intéressante est la plus importante de
sa carrière
c'est incroyable ça il va falloir voir
ce café duda ça peut être une finale ça
aussi dude artemiev au nul c'est une
finale franco-française
on peut avoir le droit à une finale
franco-française
oh que non duda gagner alors il y aura
un français on sait pas lequel contre
jean-christophe duda en finale
il y aura un français il y aura un
français en finale du championnat du
monde d'échecs les amis
de français sur le podium
je ne sais pas lequel des deux sera en
finale mais c'est extraordinaire cette
victoire de maxime
incroyable il a retourné la position on
n'a pas eu le temps de le voir
le roi h1 et le matin par able
incroyable ce qu'a fait maxime quel
parti quel parti les amis quelle partie
quelle partie incroyable de maxime qui
s'impose
qui s'en posent contre magnus carlsen
c'est incroyable
et donc le départage ce sera soit soit
maxime soit firoud et oui à la fin il
pouvait plus empêcher d'approcher cette
maths ou dame g8 maths
ça peut être firoud déjà ça peut être
maxime
duda c'est sûr qu'il y est je pense un
annoncé pas sûr ça peut être très élevée
à l'est duda
ça peut être mvl duda ça peut être un
vampire ou déjà ça peut être fier rouge
à duda
on ne peut pas en fait pour le moment
on peut pas ça ne c'est là ya pas de ya
pas de site qui savent
personne ne sait il faut attendre
la conclusion
ça se joue sur les adversaires jouer au
parti d'avant
à voir
il faut attendre le truc officiel
le truc officiel
on peut pas savoir
les départage public la rendrait pas
fini on sait pas si vous savez ce que
vous savez vous savez rien il faut
attendre que toutes les parties soient
joués pour pouvoir savoir c'est
impossible de savoir avant il ya trop de
partis
à gauche à droite
c'est absolument impossible
moi je pensais même velde houde a vu les
départage avant la ronde mais tu peux
pas être sûr
cette fin de tournoi
3 ans 4 succès sûrement mvé messa je
sais que c'est sûrement mvl mais ce
qu'ils le savent non
donc tu peux on peut twitté
ce qu'on veut il ya un pourcentage de
chance le plus logique c'est que ces
nouvelles dida mais tu peux pas être sûr
tant qu'il n'ya pas le trésor
mais
samvel duda way
à la turbo de route du boeuf nous a mis
très très bien à turbo de route du
peuple nous a mis tellement bien
ce que six doivent gagner en fait yann
iem v line dudani un fil rouge a en fait
dur de dire dès lors de savoir
wen en double of du boeuf au final qui
va rien avoir du tout un
qui aura même pas une médaille
c'est turbo droit est incompréhensible
aussi autant que celle de caruana
oui tu peux pas ça dépend du résultat
des joueurs contre qui maxime à jouer
c'est tellement difficile de dire
prêt maxime a fait le tournoi plus haut
entre guillemets que
que fierro mais bon
ces marais mettre des messages à gauche
à droite ça mériterait tellement de
bannans vrai
beaucoup de tweets de chez un officiel
disent que c'est ns mais pas sur wii
mais en fait ils savent pas c'est juste
que ça doit être élevée elle mais en
fait tu sais pas à 100%
en tout cas de français sur le podium ça
c'est sûr
il va falloir connaître la couleur de la
médaille
ce qui à mon avis quasiment sûr c'est
que c'est pas mvl firoud
ça c'est quasiment sûr
kkl fin de journée on vit ensemble ça
mérite une petite pub avant de savoir
la petite pub qui par la petite pub à ce
qui fait du bien
mederi fraîche un peu de partout
la petite fugue qui part
ça va se jouer
résultats des adversaires pour le moment
let's go 1go
maxime
le résultat ce sera une belle duda
[ __ ] c'est dégueu et mais il a gagné
le tournoi en fait il y aurait pas de
départager mme weil serez champion du
monde c'est terrible
c'est fait redwood assure
départage cbo 2 comme il est vrai
c'est incroyable
maxime en finale du championnat du monde
c'est un truc de ouf
on voit un petit tweet pour que les gens
arrêtent pas parce que c'est vraiment
incroyable
c'est vraiment incroyable ça
c'est vraiment incroyable finale du
championnat du monde des amis ça c'est
vraiment un truc de ouf
ça c'est vraiment un truc de ouf
je pense qu'ils ont joué sur la table y
en a moins que la télé norvégienne ne
refusant
la pression
au bout du pakistan qui pourrait être
hisser tout en haut
à st
il faut prend la pression
maxime il va le faire aujourd'hui je le
sens
c'est vrai mais tu as raison dans le
chat ça me lâcherait kev machin tu
caresse tout le temps maxime dans le
poêle parce que dans le sens du poil
parce que c'est ton ami et tout est là
là là ça ferme sa ferme quand même
beaucoup de bouchain honnêtement ça
arrête de parler un camp il y en aura un
dans le chat qui sera vice champion du
monde minimum evans champion du monde de
quoi que ce soit il m'appelle je lui
donne mon téléphone il m'appelle n'y a
pas de souci c'est énorme ce qui fait
maxime
c'est énorme ce qu'il fait
c'est énorme
il faut rester impartial rêve
complètement impartial
cette deuxième place quand même et
heureusement qu ali reza a gagné 1 ali
reza qui a donné qui a rendu un fier
service
à maxime parce que sinon ca non mais les
bonnes même si c'était les vannes
c'était maxime les bonnes
mais c'est beau quand même deux français
sur le podium 1 voilà on moi je suis
encore dans le tournoi je ne réalise pas
mais deux français sur le podium les
amis c'est à dire que là on a fait très
très mal à beaucoup de monde
deux français sur le podium des
championnats du monde d'échecs blitz
c'est quand même un truc de malade
c'est pas n'importe quoi on va avoir le
tirage au sort
en deuxième terrible
terrible
maintenue pour le stage envoient des
liens
lien passe même puis à trop de monde sur
le tchat
c'était les deux seuls français ouais on
en voyait que de heureusement
heureusement
heureusement qu'il n'y en avait que deux
fois non ça aurait été embêtant
ça fait tellement plaisir
aux moments ensemble les amis
ça fait ça fait plaisir d'avoir écourté
les vacances pour suivre ça quand même
c'est ce que j'avais dit sur sur un de
mes lives on avait dit ouais tu peux
partir en vacances pour noël et où j'ai
dit imaginer
mvl devient champion du monde je suis
passé en direct sur vacances t'imagines
genre la frustration d'une vie quoi en
tout cas c'est pour des moments comme ça
construit main
ça c'est les plus belles parties 1 c'est
les plus belles parties du monde ça
y'a pas mieux hein y'a pas mieux que des
partis comme ça
on vit pour ce genre de partie c'est les
plus belles ça doit être aller retour 3
+ 2
non il faut vraiment être là c'est
vraiment le la partie à ne pas rater
un français en finale d'un championnat
du monde
je sais pas si c'est même déjà arrivé en
fait dans quelle quelle que soit la
cadence
je sais même pas si c'est déjà arrivé
quelle que soit la cadence
ça doit deux parties en trois plus de 1
et en plus le ministre qui bat qui bat
magnus carlsen pour se qualifier en
finale il bat le champion du monde pour
se qualifier en finale
ça c'est vraiment extraordinaire et ça
c'est vraiment extraordinaire
c'est magnifique
ça va partir
six trains titre de champion du monde à
la clé
un titre de champion du monde à la clé
de ce match les amis
ce serait incroyable ça dans un palmarès
serait plus bas lac
la carrière de maxime clairement
et de la carrière de duda aussi
jean-christophe à domicile à 1 le joueur
polonais
il joue devant devant son public
je crois qu'il va gagner le championnat
d'europe ya pas longtemps d'ailleurs à
varsovie maintenant c'est un championnat
du monde qui va tenter d'aller chercher
maxime à l'extérieur
pologne il en difficulté depuis le début
du tournoi on l'a vu un
bel mené par les conditions mais qui a
réussi à se relever aujourd'hui qu'ils
allaient
c'est un titre de champion du monde là
c'est pas n'importe quoi les amis
habitent sont là les photographes aussi
la caméra qui va probablement pas faire
de travelling
je pense que maxime est très tranquille
ans il vient de battre magnus carlsen
juste avant c'est exactement ce qu'il
fallait
alors
leur
maxime qui a le meilleur des partages
c'est pas trop ce qui se passe puisque
on n'a pas le sens assez quand même duda
qui choisit même s'il a fini deuxième ok
pourquoi pas
ça change pas grand chose
c'est quoi c'est un cadeau c'est qu'avec
est-ce qu'il est fils
cdm nm c'est quoi
c'est la couleur des pièces et c'est que
c'est que ce bordel en fait
c'est une tombola sait quoi en fait
avant avant la finale et une tombola
organisée
connais pas
je crois qu'il a pris les blancs
jean-christophe dans la première c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle je pense on
préfère avoir les noirs
je pense qu'on préfère aller noir dans
la première ça permet d'avoir des blancs
dans la deuxième
mettre éventuellement pression
bon ça ça rappelle les règles donc ça
doit juste est du 3 + 2 à mon avis
aller retour le grand classique
reprend ils reprennent des boîtes
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent
c'est pas un déjà vu viennent pas de
faire ça à l'instant
j'ai pas compris là
ce qui se passe en fait
il ya plusieurs tirages au sort pour
être bien sûr c'est quoi non mais à 46
rage au sort c'est une boucle en fait
complexe la matrice a buggé way
la matrice a buggé les amis
sa dernière partie là qui va partir
rost stress
dre
pascale beaucoup de choses autour de la
table pour quelque chose d'aussi simple
joie une partie d'échecs mais bon
tiens
ils ont déjà attiré l'armageddon faty
fondé plusieurs tirages au sort
d'affilée
quel serait ce
on sait pas ce qui se passe à des
arbitres qui est sur son téléphone on
sait pas trop
navy devrait commencer très bientôt en
19h30 je pense que c'est leur ça va
partir va très très vite
mais quelle game de maxime quand même
contre magnus j'ai du mal à m'en
remettre
ça a été fort
il a été très fort
le truc de cassaigne la truite quoi
carlsen
ouais
c'est un joli troll de magnus
qui accueille le public voulait
probablement pas voir fil rouge à dans
les playoffs et la raison c'est des
partages en fait ils réussissent pas
avoir la bonne formule
stress de ouf là avec leur regard je
sais pas il marche partout prime un
stylo lui la
classe et un concours de signature
fait à duda qui va arriver en finale on
l'enlève
il mais de l'autre que l'on
fait quoi avec son stylo le frérot
qu'est-ce qui fait
pourquoi tu veux un stylo coutumes et
des stylos
c'est pour noter le résultat après la
partie
mais tu le vois pas le résultat
qu'on va en fait c'est un départage
changes alimentent les mecs vont devoir
noter le résultat à la fin de la partie
pour signer je comprends pas en fait
j'ai pas compris j'ai par l'aref en fait
et on va le voir quand même le résultat
non quand on regarde dans trop compliqué
enfin si un bout de papier quand même
pour être bien sûr
papa après 1 mais
il faut de quoi ces deux styles aulas
c'est un règlement
c'est le règlement c'est comme ça
ch'ti l'aude
je crois qu m'vila les blancs dans la
première mais je suis pas sûr
aucune idée
ouais c'est la dernière
ligne droite c'est à des photographes
qui prennent des photos je renvoie trois
quarts ça commence fait tu m'étonnes
qu'ils voulaient pas faire le départage
à 4 c à chaque fois que tu as deux gars
qui jouent faut attendre une demi-heure
pour qu'ils se mettent en face de
l'échiquier ça fait une demi heure quand
même que la ronde est terminée
j'ai pas datant pas trois petits jeux
pour jouer les tirs au but quand même
qu'on va en fait
non mais tu fais un départage pour enfin
j'ai pas la réf
sassus du lourd
voile et les cas
c'est maintenant
ou donnant matin je sais pas l'essence
est maintenant mais
mais on ne sait pas
ça va aller très vite à une fois que ce
sera parti ça va durer un quart d'heure
et de partir prend le stylo quand même
finalement à
il n'a pas voulu le laisser
on n'était pas bien sûr
c'est pas bien sûr
c'est la finale la fab c'est chaud j'ai
pas ça commence pas ça commence pas
ça discutaille un peu encore autour ça
et maxime arrive
il m'arrive il va avoir les pièces
blanches
je pense c'est lui avec
ses maximes
ça va y aller au bout du bout il ya
maxime peut être les amis au bout du
bout il y à maxime houdoud à quelle
partie extraordinaire nous attend
quand la pression est à est à son est à
son maximum
maxime est bien bien installés ils
rangent les pièces
il va envoyer un quattro est ce qu'il va
y avoir une petrov de duda
peut-être maxime qui a déjà réussi son
tournoi en quelque sorte mais il est
venu chercher un titre de champion du
monde
il est venu un titre de champion du
monde le joueur français tu es capable
tu es capable d'être allé battre magnus
carlsen
tu es capable de battre duda maintenant
allez mon maxi 1000 et concentre à fond
il est dedans quand il est comme ça mon
maxime il est imbattable je suis
quasiment persuadé qu'il va gagner s'il
est concentré comme ça il est imprenable
maxime c'est le meilleur joueur du monde
en blitz
c'est lui le patron c'est lui le boss
il est grand maxime il est immense
c'est lui c'est lui le meilleur
il faut qu'il aille le chercher duda qui
temporise qui vient pas aller maxime il
faut bien qu'ils se mettent dans sa
bulle
se vider la tête
et allez ça va partir
il peut le faire
c'est le premier très son premier titre
de champion du monde à la clé est pas le
premier champion du monde français on a
déjà eu
alexandra les kin mais ça fait ça fait
maintenant plus d'un siècle
qui va arriver la partie qui va être
extraordinaire les années un lion en
cage
maxime un requin en aquarium qui va
jaillir
et dépecer sa proie
ce raté cain qui fait attendre
ça fait penser à un france angleterre
avant un crunch ça te laisse rentrer sur
le terrain et ça ne changera sous un
swing low sweet chariot dans le stade au
tour
et je vous propose qu'on réponde par un
châle à la halle et je vous propose
qu'on enfin qu'on antonin shalala pour
contrer le swing low sweet charlotte sha
la la la la la la
ah ah
allez maxime
chat lalala lalala
à aller maxime chat lalala lalala